[Musique]
Hervé MNou, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement s'il
vous plaît ?
Je vais essayer en fait. Je vais
recommencer assez tôt parce que euh ma
famille maternelle est Martiniicaise qui
a créé chez moi sans doute un syndrome
vers l'étranger.
Ça qu' par les créoles.
Ça par les créoles. Et euh et et ensuite
une grande partie de mon enfance, je
l'ai passé en Afrique en en République
du Congo qui n'était pas une République
à l'époque puisque c'était la F.
Et ensuite, j'ai recommencé ma carrière
en Afrique à nouveau en Côte d'Ivoire.
Donc j'ai passé autour une dizaine
d'années en Afrique avant de rentrer en
France dans l'administration des ponts
et chaussées pour réaliser le plan
routier Breton à l'époque le grand
projet de de Gaulle de faire des
autoroutes non payantes en Bretagne pour
faciliter le développement de la
Bretagne.
C'était pas le projet d'Ane de Bretagne
de faire des autoroutes non payantes ?
Plan routier Breton. très belle
expérience de de travaux.
Et puis là-dessus, pour des raisons que
je pourrais raconter parce qu'elles sont
intéressantes, je me suis aperçu que
l'administration, c'était formidable
quand on est jeune mais ça devient
compliqué quand on quand on prend de
l'âge. Et donc j'ai décidé de quitter
l'administration et c'est comme ça que
je suis rentré à EDF
euh à une époque recrutée par le grand
euh réalisateur du programme nucléaire
français qui s'appelle
Bernardberg
Michel Hugle.
Michel Lug était le directeur de
l'équipement et c'est lui qui a organisé
la réalisation. C'est pas lui qui l'a
décidé, c'est pas lui qui est
politiquement, mais c'est lui qui a
organisé industriellement
d'une façon absolument géniale
l'organisation de la construction du
programme nucléaire. C'est lui qui m'a
recruté mais malheureusement le temps
que j'arrive, il était parti puisqu'il
avait été nommé
directeur de charbonage de France. Mais
enfin, je suis quand même rentré à EDF
et j'ai commencé ma carnière à EDF sur
l'aménagement de la construction de la
première centrale de 1300 MW DDF qui
était à Paluel. Et donc là, j'ai été
plongé dans la marmite et donc les trois
premiers mois, j'ai pas compris un mot
de ce qui se racontait parce que tout
était en trigramme.
Et puis bah c'est là que j'ai fait, je
dirais comme comme dirait Obélix, je
suis tombé dans la marmite nucléaire et
puis Hug m'avait Michel Hug m'avait
recruté parce que mon ambition était de
repartir à l'international.
Mais comme lui partait, ses successeurs
m'ont dit "Mais tu as vu comment ça
s'écrit électricité de France ? euh
c'est France. Bon, je dit bon euh mais
viens quand même, c'est super
intéressant. J'appelle Michel Hug et je
lui dis "Mais ils veulent pas que
j'aille à l'international." Il me dit
"T'inquiète pas,
aussi euh aussi peu euh ont-ils de
compréhension de la réalité
internationale, ils finiront par
comprendre
viaf." Et donc j'y suis allé et 18 mois
après, j'étais donc à Paluel arrive dans
le dans les le les les cabanes dans
lequel étaient nos bureaux, le directeur
de l'équipement successeur de Michel Luc
qui me dit "C'est toi qui voulait partir
à international ?" Ben écoute, il y a
les Chinois là, ils nous ils nous
fatiguent, ils veulent absolument qu'on
aille construire une centrale nucléaire
chez eux. Je Est-ce que tu es vol Est-ce
que tu es toujours volontaire ? Pour
moi, j'avais rêvé éventuellement de
construire des ponts au Daomé ou des
barrages en Côte d'Ivoire, mais une
centrale nucléaire en Chine, ça m'avait
pas traversé l'esprit. Et c'est comme ça
que dès la fin de 1984, je suis rentré
dans le projet de construction de cette
centrale nucléaire dont j'ai été le
directeur technique. C'est-à-dire alors
là aussi ça mérite quand même de d'en
dire deux mots parce que
EDF
a accepté, les Chinois ont confié à EDF
la responsabilité technique de la
construction de cette centrale et mais à
l'intérieur d'une d'une entreprise
chinoise. Et donc moi j'étais le
directeur technique, mon patron était le
le le directeur de l'entreprise chinoise
mais c'est IDF qui portait la
responsabilité. Donc j'avais en fait
deux patrons et donc ça a été une
expérience assez extraordinaire parce
que les décisions technique étit pris
par EDF dans le cas dans dans le cadre
d'une entreprise chinoise. Évidemment
alors ça c'était le le signe d'une
incroyable confiance de la part des
chinois de confiance àf et d'une
incroyable en 1984 6 ans après l'ouvert
enfin le
Merci de Gaulle.
Oui. Merci de Gaulle. Euh 6 ans après
l'ouverture de la Chine, donc le le le
le règne de Daniaoping,
euh la Chine était dans son état,
c'était le tout début de du
développement et donc EDF a accepté de
prendre le risque d'une de de la
responsabilité
de la construction d'une centrale
nucléaire en Chine. Et donc ça ça a duré
5 ans et puis au bout de 5 ans, je suis
rentré en France pour m'occuper alors du
programme nucléaire français.
Euh donc si vau chaud et puis la fin des
des 1300 MW euh et en particulier le
fameux contrôle commande de show qui a
été une une affaire incroyablement
difficile et qui a fini par
éclore grâce à Athos et aux ingénieurs
des DF du contrôle commande le plus
sophistiqué du monde qui est directement
lié à l'organisation. on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'y revenir. L'organisation
industrielle d'EDF qui est tout à fait
particulière et qui fait que EDF a à la
fois la la conception, l'exploitation et
donc le retour d'expérience et la
capacité d'améliorer
son processus comme tout industriel, ce
qui n'est pas le cas des autres des
autres exploitants du monde. Mais bon,
c'est c'est un peu une parenthèse. Et
donc le donc je me suis occupé de de ça
et puis ensuite
ensuite j'étais responsable du
développement et donc à la fois le plan
le programme nucléaire français et ce
qui se passait en Chine, c'est-à-dire la
la fin de la construction de la centrale
de Daabé et le début de la centrale de
la construction de la centrale de
Lingau.
Et puis ensuite
à l'arrivée de François Rousli qui avait
comme de Gaulle un syndrome chinois,
il a il a je dire réorganisé
l'entreprise
DF en créant des branches. Il a créé une
branche Asie-pacifique et donc je suis
reparti en Chine au début des années
2000 comme directeur de la branche
Asie-Acifique. est là pour assister à
j'espère l'occasion d'y revenir au
développ au vrai programme nucléaire
chinois qui aujourd'hui est un des plus
grands du monde et donc participer à la
fois à la conception et pas vraiment à
la construction mais à la conception et
à la mise en place de ce programme
et puis aussi au développement de d'un
certain nombre de projets dans
l'hydraulique, le charbon et cetera.
Dans le même temps, on a fait un très
très magnifique programme, un magnifique
projet de de barrage au Laos, barrage de
Namton qui probablement dans l'histoire
unique au monde, c'est-à-dire que après
10 ou 15 ans de développement très
compliqué et cetera, c'est un barrage
qui a été construit à 3 mois près dans
les délais annoncés et au dollars près
dans le coût annoncé. Je veux dire euh
vraiment exceptionnel dans un endroit
sublime dans la dans la forêt vierge
la haussienne et puis un très beau cycle
combiné à gaz au Vietnam. Bon enfin donc
voilà. Et puis euh ensuite donc Henry
Progliot m'a appelé comme directeur de
la production et de l'ingénierie
à à EDF en 2010
où je suis resté avec lui jusqu'en 2015
avant de repartir en Chine 2 ans et de
prendre une retraite bien méritée qui me
conduit aujourd'hui à m'intéresser
particulièrement aux questions d'énergie
et essayer de voir comment
redonner du sens à et et une direction,
une vision dans un dans un domaine qui
semble avoir complètement perdu euh son
sa boussole.
Alors, merci pour cette transition. Euh
on va parler euh géopolitique ce soir,
géopolitique de l'énergie. On va parler
de la Chine, de la France surtout, de
l'Europe surtout et on va commencer par
le la planification.
Est-ce que vous
quel regard vous portez sur la
planification
énergétique française ? Pour vous, c'est
bien planifié. Il y a des gens qui ont
une conscience à long terme de ce que la
France en terme de besoin va devoir
générer pour assumer sa croissance,
assumer sa politique énergétique
auprès de l'Europe. Comment vous sentez
notre pays ? Alors là, on est dans une
situation de guerre et on est aussi dans
une situation de divers clément. On va
ressortir avec des stocks de gaz
relativement importants à la fin de
l'hiver. Ça va être problématique aussi
de les reconstruire après l'hiver. Mais
la planification française après 2015,
elle part à volau. C'est de la traîrise,
c'est de l'incompétence, c'est de la
forfaiture.
C'est quoi ?
Euh je pense que il y a un peu de tout
ça,
y compris la forfaiture
peut-être. En tout cas, ce qui est
clair, c'est que
il y a des pressions d'ordre idéologique
qui sont portées par des gens dont
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça de la
forfaiture, mais en tout cas, s'ils ne
sont pas conscients de ce qu'ils font,
en tout cas, ils travaillent pas pour la
France. En ce sens-là, on peut peut-être
utiliser
d'après vous, il travaillent pas pour la
France. C'est clair.
Euh et ces gens-là ont depuis, je dire
progressivement de plus en plus de
d'influence
au sein de l'administration et du
gouvernement, j'allais dire depuis 40
ans. Et ça n'a fait que s'aggraver.
Et donc alors que la
parle de qui là ? Je parle de
l'idéologie de deux idéologies qui sont
presque enfin il y en a une qui est
antérieure, c'est l'idéologie dite euh
écologique qui est en fait une idéologie
plutôt grunonne, c'est-à-dire
antinucléaire avant d'être écologique
puisque on le voit aujourd'hui, ils sont
prêts à
faire passer le gaz avant le nucléaire.
Le charbon non
le charbon et le gaz. Donc toute la
question de la taxonomie, c'est
le charbon non plus, ils font pas passer
le charbon hein. Non, mais aujourd'hui,
ils sont bien obligés d' Mais bon, on
reviendra là-dessus. Mais donc
il y a une cette idéologie, c'est une
idéologie d'abord antinucléaire
et qui et qui est venue comment
dirais-je converger avec une autre qui
est ce que j'appelle l'idéologie de la
concurrence, l'idéologie de la
dérégulation et qui a conduit à des
effets encore plus délétaires dans
l'organisation de la France. les deux
idéologies venant à peu près du même
endroit.
C'est qui est l'endroit ?
L'Allemagne.
Euh
c'est encore eux. Je sais pas si c'est
encore eux mais il se trouve que
l'idéologie des vertes est complètement
alimentée. Elle a été d'ailleurs elle
vient probablement euh d'origine est
probablement la fin de la guerre et
la la
façon dont cette guerre s'est terminée.
Et donc les vaincus sont quand même
traumatisés par la bombe atomique. Et
puis ensuite
la volonté des des Américains de mettre
sur le sol allemand des missiles leur a
fait très peur. Et les Russes, les
l'Union soviétique a alimenté cette peur
antinucléaire et alimenté le mouvement
vert qui est devenu un parti et qui a
pris de plus en plus d'importance en
Allemagne. Donc euh
vous faites référence au dernier
LX sur le financement par les Russes de
Parti écologistes allemands, c'est ça ?
Non non non, je veux dire c'est bien
avant
bon ça c'est c'est dans la continuité
euh mais l'histoire ça commence juste
après la guerre. les les l'Union
soviétique là, le gaz c'est pas les
Unnions soviétiques, c'est les Russes.
Et donc il y a une construction
un axe
allemand allemand russe qui est plus
exactement allemand qui est alimenté
idéologiquement ou en tout cas qui est
dont l'idéologie est alimentée par les
Russes dans la
le parti communiste de l'époque.
Oui. pour pour alimenter cette cette
peur du nucléaire qui est devenu bon
alors maintenant
avant de venir à conséquence de cette
peur dire quand même que
je peux vous couper
j'en prie
vous avez des sources concernant la peur
instrumentalisée par X ou Y ? Bah euh
moi je mes sources en fait c'est l'école
de guerre économique
Oui. dans lequel qui a qui a fait
paraître un un document euh euh très
important et extrêmement bien documenté
euh en mai 2021.
On passe le bonjour à Ch Christian
Orbulou.
Absolument. Absolument. et euh qui
décrit tout ça d'une façon euh à la fois
assez précise et documentée.
Et donc le cette cette
idéologie maintenant, il faut voir
comment elle s'applique. Donc elle
s'applique en Allemagne
et
euh les organisations, les ONG
antinucléaires euh de quelle manière
elles ont été alimentées par
l'Allemagne, je ne sais pas exactement,
mais ce que je peux voir, c'est que
quand il y a des manifestations
antinucléaires sur les centrales
françaises, c'est quand même
essentiellement des Allemands qu'on
retrouve sur les tours de réfrigération
et qui sont passés par-dessus les
clôtures.
et et Greenpeace, pour ne citer qu'elle,
investit dans les énergies renouvelables
et est le bras armé de
l'antinucléarisme.
Mais par mais ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que c'est de l'antucléarisme
en France.
Ils sont antinucléaires pour la France.
On les a jamais entendu parler du
nucléaire aux États-Unis, en Angleterre
et même j'ai entendu que ils avaient
donné le une forme d'accord de principe
pour le développement du nucléaire en
Chine. Donc l'objectif c'est évidemment
de détruire le nucléaire français.
Alors je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Oui.
Parce qu'ils sont pas là pour vous
répondre. Ils ont aussi leur raison.
Peut-être pas obligatoirement sponsorisé
par des puissances étrangères. Il y a
des gens qui cotisent à Greenpeace qui
qui ont leur raison de pas vouloir
stocker des déchets un peu partout
n'importe comment, qui ont des raison de
vouloir protéger les centrales
nucléaires contre des attaques
terroristes. Ils ont leur raison,
c'est leur point de vue.
Peut-être qu'ils ont été un petit peu
stimulés d'après vous.
Ah ben toute la question est là. Je veux
dire qu'il y ait des gens de bonne foi
qui a peur du nucléaire. Je le comprends
très bien. J'essaie d'analyser
le processus de formation idéologique et
les bras armés de cette idéologie.
Je vous réouvre une parenthèse.
Oui.
Vous connaissez vous connaissez les
services français. Si vous avez
travaillé à l'étranger pour une grosse
boîte française, vous avez forcément
fait un petit déjeuner avec eux
ou un déjeuner ou un apéro ou une visite
dans le métro.
Greenpeace et les autres associations,
ils ont dû se faire ouvrir par nos
services pour savoir qui finance quoi,
qui travaille où.
Mais mais
alors si c'est jamais c'est sorti par
nos services qui nous embêté tout ça, ça
je ne sais pas, je n'ai pas accès au
services sur ce sujet-là. J'ai vu d'un
certain nombre de rapports qui mettent
en cause le financement de Greenpeace
par les gaziers essentiellement et en
particulier gazier russes. Mais je veux
dire, moi j'ai pas j'ai pas les
dossiers, les preuves et je ne fais pas
partie des services en question. Mais
donc je veux dire, je cite Greenpe mais
mais il y a en France aujourd'hui des
organisations antinucléri
donc dont je ne mets pas en cause pour
une certaine part la bonne foi. reparti.
Donc peut-être, je sais ça, je je sais
pas dire mais en tout cas euh le
ce qui est ce qui est clair, c'est que
le le principal
euh bénéficiaire
de ça, c'est l'Allemagne
parce que la France avait avec son
nucléaire
un avantage économique
massif, industriel,
économique.
économique parce que c'était
l'électricité la moins chère d'Europe
pratiquement, je parle pas de la Norvège
et de et industrielle parce que c'est
une industrie extraordinairement solide
et et aussi une une stabilité dans le
temps parce que la caractéristique du
nucléaire c'est que le combustible
compte pour très peu dans le coût de
production. Ce et donc le
le coût c'est l'investissement plus
l'exploitation. C'est donc un cours fixe
une fois que la centrale est construite
pendant 50 60 ou 80 ans.
Et après
et après il faut la démanteler.
Ça coûte combien ça ? C'est c'est c'est
dans le dans le prix c'est dans le coût
comptable de euh de l'électricité
aujourd'hui. La construction, le cycle
du combustible, y compris
l'enfouissement du combustible et le
démantellement des centrales est
aujourd'hui inclus dans les le coût de
l'électricité
et ça et ça n'empêche pas l'électricité
française d'être une des moins chères
d'Europe, en tout cas deux fois moins
cherre que l'électricité allemande.
quand on a des réacteurs qui
fonctionnent,
non mais qui fonctionnent ou qui
fonctionnent pas. Euh l'électricité qui
est produite, bon évidemment quand il
fonctionne pas c'est c'est c'est de l'ar
c'est du des gains perdus mais euh euh
je veux dire ils sont faits pour
fonctionner et ils vont fonctionner et
euh sauf accident il fonctionne. Sauf
incident technique il fonctionne.
On continue sur le nucléaire. On y
revient un peu plus tard
comme vous voulez.
Bon on y revient un peu plus tard.
Parlons un peu géopolitique.
La Chine quand on est français, jeune,
motivé, beau gosse,
quand on débarque là-bas, est-ce qu'on
se fait approcher par les services
chinois et comment ?
Alors, ça ne m'évoque rien. Euh moi, je
suis arrivé dans une d'abord je suis
arrivé pendant une période de
négociation. Donc ma surprise
euh mon choc a été culturel. Je suis
dans un monde
totalement différent
euh dans lequel j'apprends
progressivement à comprendre les codes
et à
réaliser à quel point notre mode de
pensée
de notre mode de relation
est différent.
Alors ensuite et et donc pour moi c'est
ça le plus important mais pour pour vous
donner une anecdote qui est très
significative de ce que j'ai les
négociations étaient étaient assez
dures.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par dur ?
Bah c'estàdire on est en face de gens
qui ont des masques de négociateurs.
J'appelais ça j'appelais ça le la
négociation
la la théorie de la poire en deux.
C'est-à-dire que le matin, il y a une
poire et puis à midi, il s'est toujours
rien passé. Ils sont un pas vide et
cetera et donc on fait des gestes et on
dit bah on commence à donner un morceau
de la poire et puis on revient
l'après-midi, il y a plus qu'une
demi-poire et le lendemain, il reste un
quart de poire et cetera. Et donc bon
des des des discussions dures mais deux
je le soir
on sort de les négociations et on va
dîner ensemble et là c'est la fête.
Des gens extraordinairement conviviaux,
amicaux, on boit, on chante et cetera et
on se dit formidable. Maintenant ça y
est, on est amis, demain ça va être et
le lendemain c'est les mêmes que la
veille. Et donc, j'ai compris à ce
moment-là que d'une certaine manière euh
pour des raisons culturelles que
j'essaie d'analyser ensuite et de
fouiller,
le chinois public
n'a n'exprime que la position de la
Chine et le Chinois privé, c'est un bon
vivant. et et donc euh le le
cette et donc ça c'est un comment
dirais-je ? m'a donné une vision sur la
nature des relations avec les Chinois
pour comprendre que au fond en Chine la
relation prime sur la personne.
Le le monde chinois qui est en gros le
monde culturel chinois qui est né il y a
un peu plus de 3000 ans mais en tout cas
qui a été constitué le monde
sociopolitique a été constitué il y a
3000 ans. C'est un monde dans lequel ce
sont les relations qui comptent. On est
tous en relation les uns avec les autres
et quand on n'est pas en relation on
n'existe pas. Et c'est fondamental. Donc
là, j'avais écrit un moment une note qui
s'appelait la Chine, un monde sans
personne.
Euh c'està dire que le le personnalisme
n'existe pas en Chine, sauf dans un
contexte très privé. Et c'est c'est tout
à fait c'est c'est tout à fait important
comme donc ce sont ces choses-là qui
m'ont au début
en plus le mode de faire et cetera.
Je n'ai je n'ai pas alors évidemment je
me souviens on se faisait tous des films
parce que il y avait des des Chinois
avec lesquels on avait d'assez bonnes
relations et d'autres qui nous
paraissaient être
et on se faisait des films en se disant
mais celui-là c'est un représentant du
parti, il est là pour espionner, il sert
à rien, il connaît rien la technique,
pourquoi il est là et cetera. Mais au
fur et à mesure qu'on a rencontré les
gens euh je me suis aperçu que que c'est
des films qu'on se faisait. C'est un peu
au fond ma meilleure amie aujourd'hui
encore, elle a été elle est elle a
toujours été membre du Parti communiste.
Mais après, il faudrait expliquer ce que
c'est que le Parti communiste en Chine
parce que en France, en Europe, on
projette la vision du communisme
stalinien sur le communisme chinois,
mais ça n'a strictement rien à voir.
parti comme chinois, c'est les Chinois
seraient probablement pas contents de
m'entendre dire ça, mais c'est une
survivance du mandarina. C'est le mode
pour le pouvoir de pénétrer la
population et d'avoir le retour
de la réalité de la réalité populaire de
ce qu'est vraiment la Chine. Et donc moi
je dis d'une façon un peu provocatrice
et et paradoxale, le Parti communiste
chinois, c'est l'outil de la démocratie
en Chine.
Et donc le le il y a il y a cette donc
les gens sont dans un mode de à la fois
de d'expression
publique
ou privé et dans un mode qui est
toujours un mode de relation.
Merci beaucoup.
Hop, je lisais dans vos pensées.
Donc petite introduction sur la Chine.
Euh
le PR chinois il fonctionne, il
fonctionne pas. Il en est où ?
Il fonctionne
le PR français. Il fonctionne ? Il
fonctionne ?
Non, il fonctionne pas.
Alors oui,
comment ça se fait ?
Alors,
on va revenir sur la Chine. He
vous voulez que je vous raconte
l'histoire de l'oper ?
Ouais. Et puis vous lâchez.
Non, non, je pas. Oui, enfin bon.
Alors, je reviens sur l'organisation
industrielle des DF.
EDF est
une des entreprises d'électricité unique
au monde qui est un industriel
d'électricité. Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
industriel ? Un industriel, c'est
quelqu'un qui a non pas qui produit un
produit, c'est quelqu'un qui a la
maîtrise de son outil de production.
Les les Michelins, c'est pas de savoir
faire des pneus, c'est de savoir faire
les usines qui savent faire les pneus.
Et c'est comme ça qu'il y a à travers le
monde euh des usines qui fabriquent des
pneus Michelins et qui ont une
ingénierie commune dans lequelle revient
le retour d'expérience de toutes ces
usines et chacune a son business plan et
ça et ses besoins et les besoins de sa
clientèle et les produits peuvent
varier.
La la production d'électricité nucléaire
dans le monde, elle a été faite dans 90
% des cas clé en main par des
constructeurs général électrique,
Westingas,
Mitsubishi, Toshiba, Jeanasse, Simas qui
confie à des à des
exploitants des centrales,
mais les exploitants ils connaissent pas
central, c'est comme si vous leur
confiez une voiture quoi. C'est quand il
y a un problème, ils appellent le
constructeur.
Euh
c'est et et c'était le cas dans tous les
chaque fois qu'il y a eu un accident,
c'éit un problème d'exploitation.
Un incident. Oui, là il y a eu des
accidents
Sri Mary Island, Tchernobyl et
Fukushima, il y en a pas eu énormément
mais il y a eu des des accidents et il y
a toujours eu des problèmes de des
problèmes liés à des problèmes
d'exploitation.
EDF
dès la première centrale Fessonheim a
mis en place un service d'ingénierie et
tirer le retour d'expérience de Fonheim
pour construire la suivante et tirer le
retour d'expérience de l'exploitation
des premières pour pour modifier les
suivantes. C'està dire qu'il y a un
cycle industriel
ou militaire
ou militaire je sais pas si militaire
en terme d'organisation. Ah oui, mais
non, mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que
la caractéristique de l'industrie si les
problèmes quand il y a un problème sur
une voiture Peugeot euh immédiatement
prendre le retour d'expérience. Je dis
ça parce que toutes les tous les
incidents et même les suggestions
d'amélioration de fonctionnement sont
intégrées dans l'ingénierie qui rétrofit
dans les centrales en conception, en
construction et en exploitation. Ce qui
fait que le parc des DF est un parc qui
est qui a été standardisé
progressivement, bien qu'il y ait euh
sep modèles de centrales différentes.
Exactement l'inverse des Allemands qui
ont un modèle euh qui est qui est le
modèle convoi de SIMAS qui est unique et
donc il y a l'effet de série. Sauf que
chaque exploitant a eu des exigences
différentes et que c'est c'est que c'est
Simince qui a discuté avec les autorités
de sûreté. Ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
les centrales des DF sont en permanence
amélioré techniquement parce que on
introduit dans le fonctionnement les les
le résultat du retour d'expérience. tous
les 10 ans pour les pour les épreuves
décénales, on introduit toutes les
modifications sur l'ensemble du parc
DDF.
Et donc euh donc ça c'était donc le CP0,
CP1, les 34 tranches de 900 MW, puis les
les 20 de 1300 MW, puis les 4 de N4 et
là on était en train d'étudier ce qu'on
appelait le REP 2000 ou N4 plus pour la
suite et puis est tombé une décision
politique, il faut faire un réacteur
franco-allemand
et a commencé une négociation. Donc les
German
faut exploser, il faut expliquer ce que
vous appelez projet politique.
Bah parce que c'était en train de
canner.
Elmun Simens était en faillite enfin la
partie nucléaire de Sims qu'avait eu
était en faillite et Elmunkol est venu
voir est venu voir Mitteran en lui
disant ça va être formidable, on va
faire un truc ensemble.
ça faisait la 3e ou 4e fois qu'il
perdait les appels d'offre derrière la
France forcément puisque on était deux
fois moins cher que je j'ajoute
d'ailleurs euh pour une petite
parenthèse dans par rapport au sujet que
je disais tout à l'heure, c'est que le
le coût de construction des centrales
françaises
bien que on n jamais mégoté sur quoi que
ce soit c'est deux fois moins que le
coût de construction des centrales
allemandes pour la raison que CDF qui
maîtrisait les fournisseurs la
discussion avec l'autorité de sûreté et
cetera, ce qui était pas le cas en
Allemagne. Deux fois moins cher qu'en
Allemagne, trois fois moins cher qu'au
Japon.
Et donc euh le Munc va voir Mitéran, lui
dit "On va faire un truc ensemble, il
est génial, on va faire bus, pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas du nucléaire ?" Sauf
que c'est alors est-ce qu'il avait des
arrières-pensées sur le fait ? On est on
est en faillite.
Soit on va entraîner entraîner nos
meilleurs amis dans la faillite, soit
ils vont nous sortir de l'eau. Je sais
pas quel c'est mobile mais en tout cas
le fait c'est que
arrêt du processus industriel. Et là, on
rentre dans une discussion où il fallait
mettre d'accord les ce qu'on appelle les
German Utilities
euh et DF, les deux les exploitants
correspondants, les autorités de sûreté
françaises et allemandes. Je rappelle
que les autorités de sûreté allemandes,
les exigences allemandes sont déjà bien
supérieures à nôtre parce qu'ils avaient
peur déjà des des chutes d'avion et
cetera.
et euh et le la tutelle des autorités de
sûreté allemande, c'était le fameux
docteur Fischer qui était un
antinucléaire notoire et donc qui a qui
a dit explicitement "Je tuerai le
nucléaire par son économie". Bon, est-ce
que ça a eu des conséquences directes ?
Je n'en sais rien. En tout cas, le
résultat
c'est que on a commencé à discuter.
Alors, il faut dire comment les choses
se passe parce que à l'époque Framô
euh est responsable de ce qu'on appelle
la chaudière, c'est-à-dire le cœur du
réacteur avec les les les systèmes
directement liés au réacteur et puis EDF
a la conception de l'ensemble de la
centrale.
de l'autre côté s'im à l'ensemble de
tout puisque c'est eux qui construisent
clé en main pour les exploitants. Et
donc les discussions sur la chaudière
ont eu lieu entre Framô et SIMAS et sur
l'ensemble de la centrale sur tout le
reste entre EDF et SIMAS.
Et ce qui s'est passé, c'est que euh
bon, moi j'étais responsable de l'unité
dans laquelle on faisait le basic design
de le PR et le directeur des études
était le directeur du projet Basic
Design de l'EPR. Et il rentrait le soir
et il me disait finalement
finalement les solutions allemandes
pourquoi enfin on pourrait très bien les
accepter. Elles sont pas forcément
beaucoup moins bonnes que les nôtres. le
résultat. Mais je dis ça parce que au
fond chez EDF euh il y a aucun intérêt
commercial. Euh c'est un service public.
que on a des fournisseurs
les il est moins évident que Sim n'ait
pas eu d'arrière pensée à ce moment-là
parce que eux toutes leur fourniture ça
vient de leur ça vient de de de filial
et donc en acceptant les solutions SIM
on a accepté les fournitures SIM et donc
on a fait un réacteur qui est devenu
largement allemand en tout cas qui pour
lequel on a perdu
le la filiation industrielle dont je
parlais tout à l'heure.
En plus, comme il a fallu ajouter des
enceintes supplémentaires plus une peau
d'étanchéité plus un récupérateur de
corium plus un 4e
un 4e et même un 5e circuit de sûreté et
cetera, c'est devenu hors de prix. Et
pour passer dans ce qu'on pensait être
le prix cible, il a fallu augmenter le
volume, la la puissance. Et donc on a
fait
appeler les choses comme on peut appeler
les choses comme on veut un monstre. Et
ce monstre
euh il a aujourd'hui pour 200
MW de plus que le M4 quatre fois plus de
ferraill et deux fois plus de béton.
Et donc et puis en plus des dispositions
constructives qui sont très compliquées
et en plus des règles de de sûreté qui
euh se sont venus sont ont été aggravés
dans cette période enfin renforcé. Avant
pour donner un exemple pour mettre des
chemins de câble, on fait des trous dans
les murs et on en on enfile des spit et
on pose le chemin de câble dessus.
Maintenant, est-ce que ce sont des
platines ancrées ? C'est-à-dire que
c'est une platine sur laquelle on va
venir souder le chemin de câble, mais
derrière il y a des
du ferraillage. Et le problème c'est que
le ferraillage il faut le faire rentrer
dans le ferraillage de la de de et et
dans la plupart des cas ça passe pas
parce qu'il y a tellement de ferraillage
de base et comme en plus il se trouve
que le le detail
le detail design donc le le la
conception finale de détail n'était pas
complètement faite il a fallu faire
beaucoup de modification donc c'était un
enfer pour le génie civil sans sans
compter, bon sans compter effectivement
le fait d'une perte de compétence dans
le domaine métallurgique parce que quand
on ne quand on ne fait pas de quand on
ne réalise pas de réacteur pendant plus
de 10 ans, les industries restent pas la
clé du la le petit doigt sur la couture
du pantalon en attendant que on leur
dise que ça peut redémarrer. Et donc
effectivement, les compétences se sont
dispersées. Et quand il a fallu refaire
un EPR aussi compliqué, pour un EPR, on
ne remobilise pas une industrie
complète. Je veux dire le le nucléaire
ça coûte cher du point de vue de
l'organisation de la qualité, du point
de vue de la sûreté, ça demande des la
mise en place des investissements
considérables. On ne fait pas ça pour
euh pour euh
pour une opération. Et donc le le PR a
le PR de Flamandville a souffert de ces
problèmes de métallirurgie. presque tous
les problèmes euh qui ont conduit à des
délais importants viennent de problèmes
de soudage et de métallurgie. Et donc
le le la difficulté constructive parce
que au au
[Musique]
en Chine, ils ont réussi à le démarrer.
Ils ont quand même mis beaucoup plus de
temps que prévu et un peu plus d'argent.
Mais à l'époque quand ils ont engagé le
le PR en Chine, ils construisaient 10
centrales nucléaires par an. Donc ils
avaient les soudeurs, ils avaient le
tissu industriel. Nous, on avait plus on
avait plus. Et donc ça explique euh le
décalage
quant à la Finlande,
c'est un peu le syndrome c'est un peu le
syndrome français parce queil y avait
pas Sims et et Areva n'était pas du
point de vue industriel en dans l'état
de de construire ça dans les délais et
dans les coûts annoncés.
Je me fais encore du diable
comme ça ça vous laisse
vous éclaircir le chat.
sur les mesures plus coercitives en
question de sécurité, c'est un cendrier
pour récupérer le corium,
de faire des des infrastructures
renforcées contre des nouvelles menaces
telles de terroriste ou de tremblement
de terre ou de sécheresse.
C'est des arguments qui sont aussi
entendables
quand vous on vous dit voilà maintenant
il y a des cinglés qui peuvent détourner
un avion et se jeter sur une piscine de
stockage qui n'est protégé que par de la
toile en tôle.
C'est quand même légitime.
Mais bien sûr. Non, mais je dis pas que
les mesures sont pas sont
tremblement de terre, c'est aussi
légitime.
Oui, mais enfin
une bonne sécheresse
Oui.
pour un réacteur,
c'est autre chose ça.
C'est autre chose.
Oui, parce que le l'eau c'est un sujet
c'est un c'est un sujet différent. C'est
pas un sujet. Bon non mais je dis pas
que c'est pas j'ai pas dit que c'était
pas légitime. Ce que je dis, c'est que
la mesure ou la le niveau des mesures
qui sont prises sont
à un un tellement le niveau est
tellement élevé que ça devient et et que
en plus on a on a on n pas comment
dirais-je
on n pas une vision industrielle de la
construction de ce réacteur.
les les les
comment dire les cloisons ne sont pas
superposés suivant les étage. Donc ça
enfin c'est c'est on a une on a je veux
dire le la perte de compétence dans le
domaine de la métallurgie a été aussi
une perte de compétence dans le domaine
de la conception.
Et on vient de se faire déclasser d'un
coup là non ? On se retrouve avec
Non mais vous savez
l'industrie
et j'espère qu'on en reparlera parce que
c'est tout l'enjeu pour l'avenir.
L'industrie, elle se développe là où il
y a un programme d'industriel. Elle se
qui donne le cap ? Mais
bien sûr.
Non mais qui donne le cap ? Bah
en principe c'est une politique
qui donne la vision.
En tout cas je peux vous donner je vais
vous donner un exemple.
Un mandat un mandat maintenant c'est 4
ans pour le président. Mais d'accord.
Mais euh mais après euh
je veux dire euh le premier le premier
programme
c'était 7 ans,
maintenant c'est 5 je crois. Euh le
premier programme c'était 7 ans. Il a
été poursuivi de 1970
à 1998.
Donc c'est possible et même avec des
gens comme François Mitéran qui avait
fait campagne pour arrêter le programme
nucléaire. Mais bon, il s'est aperçu que
qu'il a quand même eu ce réalisme, on
dire sur le plan économique aussi, ce
réalisme de se dire "Mais si on arrête
le nucléaire, avec quoi on va faire ?"
Alors, il y a de la réponse allemande,
on va le faire avec du vent. Ça a pas
l'air de marcher non plus tellement
bien. Bon donc le quand
il y a du vent ça marche bien.
Oui, ça marche quand il y a du vent mais
sauf que les trains il ils attendent pas
qu'il y ait du vent pour démarrer quand
c'est
pas des trains à voile.
Je fais des bouilles.
Bon le
je vous recoupe.
Oui.
Vous avez dit quelque chose de très
intéressant. La vision de cap pour aller
où ? Je vais je vais je vais vous je
vais vous insulter d'ailleurs.
Allez-y. Je croyais que c'était interdit
à cette émission. Petit boomer.
On va où là ? Quand quand je vois quand
j'entends Oui, la croissance repart.
Sans énergie, il y a pas de croissance.
Non, on quand on discute avec des
ingénieurs, l'ingénieur il est bêt et
discipliné. Il a sa conception, il fait
il fait c'est un opératif.
Là, je vous demande de sortir un petit
peu de votre
camisole d'ingénieur.
Le cap pour aller où ? C'est-à-dire on
continue la croissance taquet. On
demande à nos ingénieurs de nous faire
de des centrales taqué pour faire
ensuite des petites chaussettes en Chine
ou faire des petits machins en plastique
au Bangladesh ou des choses comme ça.
Vous voyez comment le cape et vous voyez
comment l'arrivée vers quoi ? Si on on
veut retrouver une croissance à 3 %, il
nous faut combien de terra disponible ?
Si on veut une croissance à 18 %, il
nous faut combien de terra ? Le cap, il
va où selon vous avec votre vision de
boomer ? On va sur continue les trois
voitures électriques, les trois maisons
de campagne, on continue à manger du
saumon fumé matin, midi et soir. On on
pète dans la soie avec les l'héritage
français de nos colonies, de nos
ingénieurs qui ont bossé.
On crame l'héritage de Mamifrance. Mais
on va où ?
Mais
me demandez pas enfin, comment dirais-je
? Pour moi, depuis l'origine des temps,
l'énergie a servi à désasservir les
hommes.
Euh au début, il fallait partir à la
chasse pour bouffer. Euh après, il a
fallu avoir un soc de charrue en bois.
On se levait à 6h du matin, on se
couchait à 11h du soir après avoir trité
les vaches et cetera. C'est l'énergie
qui libère l'homme et qui fait de
l'homme quelqu'un de libre par rapport à
ces qui lui donne la possibilité de
faire autre chose que de bosser à
longueur de journée pour survivre. Donc
la démocratie était un un épithénomène.
Ah mais c'est une organisation
socio-politique. C'est pas le le c'est
je dirais il y a des tas d'endroits qui
sont pas démocratiques ou en tout cas au
sens où on l'entend et qui ont la même
logique. Le l'énergie est ce qui bah
d'ailleurs même c'était la formule de
l'énine
le le le soviétique c'est le communisme
avec de avec l'électricité ou l'inverse
peu importe. Mais mais bon donc c'est
absolument aujourd'hui alors les le
monde
évolue. Est-ce qu'il faut manger du
saumon fumé tous les jours ? Je suis pas
du tout convaincu que ce soit ça
l'objectif mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que il y a une il y a une évolution
aujourd'hui. Bah tous ces matériels
informatiques qui nous sertent bien, on
est quand même très content. Qu'est-ce
que ça va donner dans 10 ans, j'en sais
rien. Mais ce qui est sûr, c'est que ça
concentre de plus en plus d'énergie. Et
donc l'objectif que l'on a depuis
l'origine des temps, c'est de produire
cette énergie. On a réussi en France à à
produire une énergie abondante, pas
chère, sûre, efficace.
Pourquoi ça prévrait ? Je veux dire
ensuite ensuite la vision la vision
sociopolitique la vision je dirais là ça
relève des des de comment dirais-je de
de choix
personnel et collectif où où la
démocratie intervient. on dit on va on
veut la on voit ce qu'on veut faire de
la France mais c'est c'est un autre
sujet que le fait que plus on aura
d'énergie bon encore une fois accessible
abondante et bon marché et plus on sera
libre ça pour moi c'est une
libre pour faire quoi ?
avec une bouche en canard
mais mais chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais
ça peut être pour lire ou aller au
cinéma ou écouter Singer Viiew. Euh bon
mais c'est c'est quand même mieux que de
que de labourer les champs. Enfin, il y
a il y a des gens qui pensent le
contraire, mais de temps en temps, c'est
bien de la bourer. Mais donc euh Non,
mais ça ramène à la un peu à la réalité
qu'on a tendance à perdre de vue parce
qu'effectivement euh avec TikTok et
Instagram, on sait plus très bien où et
quoi. Mais bon, passons. Donc encore une
fois, moi je suis pas je suis pas là
pour définir
le le
le sens collectif que nous voulons
donner à notre collectivité nationale.
Si si c'est encore le cas, c'est ce que
j'espère.
Euh en tout cas, c'est pas le cas pour
tous malheureusement, mais euh
donc c'est pas moi qui vais le définir.
Je peux le souhaiter mais je peux pas le
définir. En revanche, ce dont je suis
sûr, c'est que cette collectivité
nationale
n'a que des avantages à tirer d'une
énergie
encore une fois efficace, abondante et
accessible. Bon et donc voilà. Alors
pour revenir sur ce sujet, si vous
permettez,
et ben non.
dire, on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation absolument incroyable
où pour des raisons idéologiques donc
vraisemblablement importé euh on est en
train de nous expliquer que le nucléaire
il faut le réduire au profit d'énergie
renouvelable.
Alors,
je voudrais juste faire un un tout petit
point sur le sujet parce que le le en
Europe,
d'abord, il faut partir d'une réalité
qui est à la fois incontestable et sans
doute pour longtemps, je sais pas
combien de temps mais sans doute pour
longtemps, l'électricité n'est pas
stockable. Donc il faut la produire à
chaque seconde
pour la consommation qui est appelée.
Quand un TGV démarre, il faut mettre en
face la production. Quand vous allumez
votre ordinateur, il faut mettre en face
la production. Et donc le le la la
production, elle est totalement
assujettétie à la consommation et
jusqu'à maintenant, c'est la
consommation qui guide. Et donc ça a été
un effort colossal, technique d'arriver
à estimer à l'avance
la consommation de pour l'année
prochaine, pour le mois prochain, pour
les 15 jours qui viennent, pour et pour
le lendemain et pour les 5 minutes qui
viennent. Et donc c'est une organisation
de sollicitation des moyens de
production pour répondre instantanément
à la
on a euh et donc
on a construit ça en France avec du
nucléaire et de l'hydraulique
essentiellement et une part de gaz.
En fait, en Europe,
le pic de consommation, c'est-à-dire la
consommation maximum, c'est parce qu'il
y a pas de foisonnement en Europe. En
gros, quand il y a des tempêtes, c'est
sur toute l'Europe. Quand il y a du
vent, c'est sur toute l'Europe, on l'a
vu récemment. Et quand il y a pas de
vent, il y en a pas en Europe
généralement. Et donc le pic de
consommation, c'est un soir d'hiver
quand il y a une haute pression qui fait
froid. Il y a pas de vent, pas de
soleil. Et donc il faut avoir en Europe
en particulier en France un parc de
production qui soit capable de couvrir
le maximum de la consommation.
Ça s'appelle
l'Assemblée nationale.
C'est là où ça brasse du vent quand
même. Non.
Ben non mais justement
c'est pas pilotable.
C'est pas pilotable. Ah bah c'est pas
l'assemblée monsieur. Quoi qu'c un petit
coup de bâton ça devrait les piloter un
peu. En tout cas
une petite cage à hamster une petite
roue.
En tout cas les moyens pilotables que
l'on connaît il y en a pas 36, il y en a
quatre. Il y a le charbon et la le lite
le gaz l'hydraulique et le nucléaire. Il
faut choisir entre ces et aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne a un parc de production qui
est le même en pilotable depuis 1990.
Ils n'ont pas réduit le parc de
production depuis 1990. Ils ont
seulement construit
au-dessus de ces 100 GW de pilotable 120
GW ou 130 Go de renouvelable. En France,
on a un parc qui est à 80 % qui était
qui est même monté jusqu'à 85 %
nucléaire, 7 ou 8 % hydraulique et le
reste en gaz. On est obligé d'avoir euh
donc du pilotable pour la pointe.
Et donc le renouvelable,
le éolien et solaire ne vient que se
substituer à des moyens pilotables
parce que encore une fois le parc doit
être complet pour le maximum.
Quand c'est du charbon ou du linite
comme en Allemagne et ben on peut dire
que on économise de la production de CO2
puisque quand il y a du vent on brûle
pas de charbon. Très bien. Faut voir à
quel coup parce que ils ont dépensé
aujourd'hui entre 500 et 600 milliards
pour avoir ce parc éolien. Donc il faut
voir quel est le coût de la tonne de CO2
évité. Mais bon, mais en France où on a
90 % de la production qui est euh
hydraulique et nucléaire, c'est-à-dire
sans émission de CO2, le renouvelable ne
fait que se substituer à du
à du nucléaire et de l'hydraulique. Et
donc, on arrête le nucléaire pour
laisser passer le vent.
Ce qui fait que comme le nucléaire coûte
le même prix qui tourne ou qui tourne
pas, c'est deux fois plus cher. Et donc
en France euh rajouter alors qu'il y a
250 GW d'éolien en Europe, on l'a vu
donc en décembre, décembre première
semaine de décembre, pas un souffle
d'air, il fait froid.
Il faut faire tourner les centrales à
charbon et EDF achète à cause des
problèmes sur le nucléaire achète de
l'électricité 580 € l'électricité du
charbon allemand à 580 € le mWh.
Chun
chun
le 15 jours après euh
vend sur sur l'Europe euh tout le monde
a tout le monde a trop d'électricité le
prix de l'électricité tombe en dessous
de zéro.
Et donc et donc à ce moment-là F export
parce qu'on peut pas arrêter toutes les
centrales parce qu'il y a des pics donc
export à a des prix nuls ou négatifs
alors qu'il a acheté une semaine avant
de l'électricité charbonnée. Bon donc
aujourd'hui avec 250 Go d'éolien en
Europe, rajouter 1 seul GW en France est
totalement absurde, économiquement
absurde. Alors maintenant à qui ça ça
profite ? Et bien le
ça profite
c'est ce système là qui vient qui vient
d'Allemagne
profite au fait que qui nous oblige et
par l'intermédiaire de la Commission
européenne à augmenter la part de
renouvelable. Donc aujourd'hui, il y a
des règlement des réglementations qui
nous qui vont qui ont été validées par
la France pour atteindre 40 % de
renouvelable dans la dans le le mix
énergétique. Ça veut dire ça n'a pas
encore été c'est pas encore passé mais
ça c'est c'est en processus.
Et donc on va arrêter du nucléaire.
L'idée suivant laquelle
le renouvelable qui est d'ailleurs
malheureusement
soutenu
publiquement par EDF, que le
renouvelable est complémentaire du du
nucléaire, c'est absurde. Le
renouvelable se substitue au moyen de
production pilotable quand il y a du
vent et du soleil. Si c'est du
nucléaire, ben on paye deux fois, on
paye le nucléaire plus le renouvelable.
Et donc alors pourquoi on narrête pas ?
On narrête pas parce que la commission
sous pression allemande nous oblige à le
faire. Mais pourquoi en France onarrête
pas ? Alors je sais pas. Ce que je sais
c'est que il y a d'énormes intérêts
financiers derrière. vous appelez énorme
des centaines de milliards.
Euh le
le l'éolien entre le début de l'éolien,
c'estàdire les début des années 2000 et
2018, le chiffre d'affaires, c'est 75
milliards. Aujourd'hui, on doit être à
100 et quelques et avec les programmes
qui sont annoncés, c'est plutôt 200 ou
250.
Les promoteurs de l'éolien
font des bénéfices qui sont entre 30 et
40 %.
Les promot
chun
chun les promoteurs de l'éolien, il y en
a 60 % qui sont des entreprises
étrangères.
et fait sur ces 60 % il y en a 60 % des
60 % qui sont allemandes
et puis en plus
Ben
et puis en plus le les promoteurs
français qui sont eux aussi s'en mettent
plein les poches ont
raison
mais non mais bien sûr que si ça dépend
ce qui si on cherche l'intérêt
particulier ou l'intérêt général mais le
ce qui ce qui euh et en plus
les
tout tout le matériel éolien et panneaux
solaires vient de l'étranger,
la Chine,
les panneaux solaires de Chine, les
éoliennes d'Allemagne ou des États-Unis,
général électrique et Gamesa Simas. Et
donc plus de 60 % du chiffre d'affaires
de l'ensemble du parc éolien français
part à l'étranger. Donc il nous reste
même les petites subventions qu'on
donne,
ça sert ça les subventions qu'on donne
sert à sert à c'est un flux constant de
d'argent vers l'étranger.
Il va falloir qu'on apprenne à faire le
cri du dindon parce queon est quand même
le dindon de la farce dans l'histoire.
Non mais je je n'arrive pas à
comprendre. Sauf que
incompétence,
je sais pas mais le problème du
renouvelable comme vous avez évidemment
compris et comme le dit j'allais dire
votre ami, je sais pas encore mais
Pouyané avec une forme de de d'innocence
merveilleuse, il dit mais derrière
chaque éolienne, il y a du gaz. C'est
exactement ce que je viens d'expliquer.
Et donc lui il voit tout l'intérêt de
l'éolien et NG, c'est pareil puisqu'ils
vendent du gaz. et les Allemands encore
plus. Et ce qui s'était produit, c'est
que les Allemands avaient comme objectif
avec Nordstream 1 et Nordstream 2
devenir
non seulement le hub de l'électricité
européenne mais le hub du gaz européen.
Et donc tout leur système est construit
pour devenir le centre de de gravité de
l'électricité et du gaz pour l'ensemble
de l'Europe.
Alors je vous coupe,
je parle sous votre contrôle.
Donc si je vous ai bien compris,
l'Allemagne nous fait une guerre
économique sournoise
par des voies diverse et varié
pour nous planter et se mettre avec un
un bonus de compétitivité
avec les Allemands.
Et c'était au départ le gaz russe.
Maintenant c'est plus le gaz russe parce
qu'ils sont un peu en le divorce se
passe mal. Ils vont nous faire le coup
avec le gazo de chiste américain ou vous
sentez grand ? Non mais ce qui est
merveilleux c'est ils vont nous rafler
tout.
Le problème c'est que quand je parle
comme ça dire bah celui-là c'est c'est
clair c'est un anti-européen. Voilà. Bon
c'est pas le cas du tout. Moi je suis
moi j'ai la vision comme dirait comme
dirait l'autre d'une Europe golienne.
C'estd on construit ensemble ce qu'on
veut construire ensemble. Aujourd'hui,
c'est pas ce qui se passe. Pour revenir
sur le gaz de chiste,
aujourd'hui au motif de la construction
européenne, on accepte tout.
et et mon impression peut-être de bonne
foi, peut-être pas de bonne fois, je
sais pas quels sont les mobiles, mais on
sent que la politique de la France
aujourd'hui
est
met
une une certaine vision de la
construction européenne au dépend de
l'intérêt français,
presque des Européens eux-mêmes
et sans doute et finalement des
Européens eux-mêmes et et peut-être même
d'ailleurs le même docteur Fischer qui a
été ensuite vice-chancelier
a dit "Aujourd'hui, l'Allemagne
utilise
l'Europe comme un outil pour sa
construction
et
et moi je le dis, la France utilise et
et la politique française utilise la
France comme outil de la construction
allem européen
Et donc c'est parfaitement asymétrique
et le docteur Ficher concluait en disant
c'est très mauvais pour l'Europe et
encore plus mauvais pour l'Allemagne.
Donc en tout cas le
alors où en étais-je ? Euh
jeune
Non mais le dire quelque chose.
Guerre économique allemande.
Oui.
Ah oui le G à l'envers. Gaz. Oui. Oui.
Pourquoi ? Ils ont fait un partenariat
toxicoman dealer avec les Russes pour se
mettre en première page, en première
marche.
Ça s'est mal passé.
Alors après ça s'est mal passé, c'est
pas forcément la faute des Allemands, je
veux dire
forcément
mais mais en tout cas mais mais ils se
sont quand même mis l'accord au coup.
Non mais je veux dire il y a une
stratégie allemande qui était un axe un
axe germanoorusse hein. C'est pas
récent. Et donc ça aurait pu marcher
dans un bon moi je je leur jette pas la
pièce
d'ailleurs la plus grande peur des
Américains. D'où d'où la situation
actuelle vraisemblablement mais ce que
je veux dire pour revenir sur le sur le
gaz de chist on a des terminaux de LNG
les Allemands n'en avaient pas et donc
on fournit de du gaz aux Allemands. Donc
maintenant ils sont en train d'en
construire.
Donc on on leur fournit notre gaz. Ils
nous fournissent leur électricité. euh
de vous faites avec du charbon et euh et
on achète leur leur
leurs éoliennes
et quelques voitures
et quelques voitures.
Je vais me faire laqu du diable.
C'est c'est devient ça devient c'est
chronique.
Ouais. Méfiez-vous parce que quand je
deviens le diable, ça devient vraiment
chaud, hein.
Les Allemands, s'ils se vautrent, c'est
toute l'Europe qui se vautre. C'est
l'euro qui se vautre. C'est les pensions
de retraite en euros qui se vont
Non mais c'est ça le problème, c'est que
pourquoi indépendamment de l'idéologie
du couple franco-allemand machin et
cetera euh comme je l'ai je l'ai écrit
dans mon livre euh peut-être qu'il nous
tiennent par la bourse.
Et donc
je veux dire, il y a beaucoup de
décisions qui sont prises parce que si
on accepte pas, on va avoir des
problèmes au niveau de dette où on est
qui est garanti par l'Allemagne.
Et donc c'est une espèce de cercle
vicieux qui est de plus en plus
circulaire et de plus en plus vicieux.
Faut peut-être qu'on fasse tomber la
Dodge Ban en premier.
Je crois qu' elle est elle est en bonne
santé en ce moment. Il faut il faut ça
va être difficile.
Trois trêves de plaisanterie. Euh je
prends une question internet qui vient.
Philip Bigwick disait que les centrales
ne seront jamais démantelées. Qu'en
pensent-il ?
Philippe Bigwick, c'est un mais un un
mec qui travaille la SNCF,
il prêche les lot. Ouais.
Ouais. Mais pourquoi il dit il dit en
gros les centrales, on va jamais les
démonter ?
Mais il y en a déjà qu'on a démonté
hein.
Lesquels ? Euhobille,
ça s'est un peu mal passé quand même
hein.
Brenilis et euh et choose
a
et donc euh pourquoi est-ce qu'on
démentraînerait pas ? Et et d'ailleurs
l'idée c'est quand même de pas
multiplier à l'infini les sites
nucléaires.
C'est aujourd'hui on va construire les
nouveaux les les nouvelles centrales
dans l'extension des sites existants. Et
puis après le s'il y a un vrai programme
comme on peut le souhaiter qui permette
à la France de redevenir un pays
industriel avec une vraie industrie dans
dans la durée et et un parc de
production
nucléaire,
on démontrera les centrales existantes
et on en mettra des neuves à la place.
Je veux dire d'ailleurs sur cette
question du de du programme industriel,
je pense que aujourd'hui je suis je suis
quand même assez stupéfait d'entendre
qu'on va réindustrier la France avec des
batteries et de l'hydrogène euh c'est
dire et et des véhicules électriques. Si
jamais
ces ces orientations ont un avenir
l'échelle que l'on dit,
le risque les chances pour que ce soit
chez nous sont quand même assez faibles
pour la réindustrialisation
par ça la en revanche la
réindustrialisation par le nucléaire je
veux dire si c'est c'est évident que non
seule chose qui nous reste en fait
c'est c'est mais c'est sur ça qu'on
so un peu taquin
Allez.
Bon, quand vous avez vu euh notre leader
charismatique Macron Emmanuel 1er
h
dire bon, on va tout fermer la nuclé h
hop hop ça suffit. Vous avez fait
combien de tours dans votre lit quand
vous l'avez entendu ?
Mais il a pas dit ça. C'est c'est
Hollande qui a dit ça. Ex.
Ouais. Hollande pardon. Bon, c'est c'est
un peu le même disciple. Oui. Non mais
vous savez, moi j'ai assisté euh à
la
décision de de fermeture du site de
Plogof,
à la décision de fermeture du site de
Créalville
euh et à la loi à la à la campagne de de
Hollande. entre-temps,
je veux dire tous les ministres de on a
on a quand même mis le ministère de
l'industrie dans la dans le ministère de
l'environnement, le ministère de
l'énergie dans le ministère de
l'environnement. C'est-à-dire que c'est
que des écolos et et pas forcément sous
des régimes socialistes. Borlot, le
grenel de malgré toute l'affection qu'on
peut avoir pour lui, mais bon mais c'est
le grenel de l'environnement.
C'est ils ont tous participé contribué à
quelque chose qui était l'air du temps
qui avait l'air d'être la sagesse
partagée qui était
appelons un ch un chat. C'était de quoi
de la subordnation de vote ? C'était
quoi du prosélitisme politique ? C'était
quoi ?
Je sais, j'en sais rien que je sais pas
vous dire
vous mouillez pas trop. Non, non, non,
mais je j'aimerais bien mouiller. Je
sais pas qu'est-ce que ces gens-là ont
dans la tête quand je C'est Non, mais
c'est vrai, c'est c'est Golen Royal qui
a été et Corine Lepage qui est avocat de
Genève contre la France pour fermer
Buget. Qu'est-ce que ces gens ont dans
la tête ? Je n'arrive pas à comprendre.
Vous allez discuter avec eux ?
Non.
Bah pourquoi ?
Ben, j'ai parce que parce qu'il me parle
pas. C'est très difficile de discuter
avec des gens comme ça.
Je suis pas d'accord avec vous. Ah ben
parce que vous avez un don que je n'ai
pas. Euh moi je leur dis, je je dis je
j'invite Greenpeace, j'invite un
procléaire, je dis le premier qui
mouffe, c'est moi qui tape. Je peux vous
dire que tout le monde se tient bien.
Vous avez vu mon physique,
il mouffte pasin. Ils sont très polis et
ça échange.
Est-ce qu'il faut peut-être faire
discuter les gens ? Mo j'ai ah je peux
non mais je peux vous dire j'ai
participé à des à des table tables
rondes machin et cetera avec des
opposants
type sortir du nucléaire et cetera il
récit un catéchisme. C'est impossible
d'avoir une discussion avec eux.
Je suis pas d'accord.
Bon ben moi c'est mon expérience.
Je vous organiserai une petite sans
table
volontiers. Voltiers
où je lance les chaises
volontiers. Je suis expert hein. H
60 m ça va vite.
Bon, on arrête les conneries. Je suis
désolé, j'ai une voix éteinte mais j'ai
fait une une intoxication alimentaire.
J'ai chanté du Johnnyité sur les Gogn
pendant 48 he c'était difficile.
Donc on va revenir à l'électrification
mondiale, l'électrification européenne,
la production électrique mondiale et
européenne. On est dans une société
mondialisée.
On est en on est encore en train de se
taper comme des petites tribus avec moi
je fais mon petit plan énergétique à
gauche, je te fais des petits crochept à
droite, je déclare des guerres à gauche,
je déclare des guerres à droite. Toi tu
as pas de ressources, moi j'en ai plein.
Il te reste un peu de technologie mais
je vais faire de l'espionnage chez toi.
Votre regard de boomer sur notre société
que votre génération nous laisse, c'est
une société qui est archaïque. C'est une
société qui a fait d'énormes progrès
parce que vous avez réduit la fin dans
le monde. C'est une société qui court à
son effondrement.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas un plan
d'électrification
européen pour commencer ? Dire voilà aux
Allemands, vous êtes bien gentils, vous
avez fait des mixeurs à chouette plein
qui ne fonctionne que quand il y a du
vent. Bon, c'est un peu compliqué. Il y
a un peu moins de vent en ce moment.
Nous, on a du nucléaire, soyons
complémentaire.
C'est pas possible de faire ça, de dire
aux espagnols, "Vous avez du soleil, on
va être complémentaire." Est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas un
gouvernement européen
plus ?
Alors, je vais vous dire, je vais vous
raconter une pousse le bouchon. Je je
vais je vais répondre euh je vais
essayer de répondre mon ma vision sur le
sujet mais je quand même vous donner un
un
une anecdote. En 1998 je suis le
représentant des DF à Eurélectrique. EUR
électrique c'est l'association des
électriciens européens pour manger des
petits fours gratos. Oh, c'était pas
c'était pas vraiment l'ambiance mais
c'est surtout c'était DF qui avait créé
ça dans l'esprit que vous dites. C'est
on est des électriciens européens,
parlons-nous comme on parlait des
régulations et cetera, il fallait
essayons de construire quelque chose
donc heure électrique.
Donc moi donc le je dire d'ailleurs que
le processus au début c'est DF qui
présidait machin et cetera et puis
progressivement c'était les Allemands
comme dans beaucoup de sujets et le
comme beaucoup tout ce qui se passe à
Bruxelles c'est comme ça mais
le donc on parle des régulations
concurrence à la production et cetera je
dis mais écoutez moi je pourquoi pas
mais si on veut faire de de un vrai une
vraie concurrence à la production où
tout le monde puisse venir, il faut un
réseau commun européen
qui n'existe pas, qui n'existe toujours
pas d'ailleurs. Et là, il y a un
allemand qui se lève et qui me dit "Bah,
vous n'y pensez pas. Si on a un réseau,
la fameuse plaque de cuivre européenne,
on va être inondé par l'énergie
nucléaire d'DF.
C'est QFV.
Pas cher,
justement.
Mais justement et donc c'est ça eux eux
ne voulaient pas de la concurrence des
DF. Donc je l' dire attendez
et donc ils se sont organisés
par l'intermédiaire de la Commission
européenne pour déclarer qu'ED était un
monopole sans s'apercevoir que c'est pas
un monopole en Europe, c'est un monopole
en France et donc vis-à-vis de l'Europe.
Bon et donc l'objectif a été de
démanteler les DF ce qui est
parfaitement réussi puisqueaujourd'hui
c'est en trois morceaux et on parle le
d'enfer 5.
Et donc le
donc je dire
l'idéal dont vous parlez euh bien sûr il
est souhaitable
mais c'est pas la Commission européenne
telle qu'elle existe qui va avoir la
légitimité.
Le gouvernement européen, il ne peut il
ne peut émaner que des volontés
nationales aujourd'hui. Le seul niveau
démocratique qui existe aujourd'hui, ce
sont les nations. Donc si on veut avoir
un un processus de convergence, il faut
que ce soit les nations qui le décident
et pas espèce d'ovni Commission
européenne dont on sait pas d'où ils
sortent et quelle responsabilité ils ont
vis-à-vis de qui. Aujourd'hui,
ils ont un plan, ils l'ont dit, on sait
pas lequel, mais ils ont un plan. Oui
oui ve plein
non mais bon donc donc
pour le moment il me semble que la
logique de la réalité nationale c'est
que et d'ailleurs c'est ce que c'est ce
qui est dans les traités qu'on a dévoyé
au profit de l'Allemagne encore une fois
mais mais ce qui est dans les traités
c'est que chaque pays chaque nation est
responsable de son mix énergétique.
Et donc pourquoi est-ce que et et ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de direction de l'énergie à
la à la Commission européenne. Il y a
une direction de la concurrence et une
direction de l'environnement. Et c'est
ce sont ces deux directions qui ont
organisé le le le découpage le massacre
à la trançonneuse de de de l'énergie
électrique en France. Je vous coupe.
Vous étiez à cette fameuse réunion, les
Allemands, ils ont dit surtout pas. Bon,
vous rentrez en France, vous appelez à
DGSE, vous leur faites écouter les gars,
vous y comprenez rien.
Je vais vous expliquer, je vais vous
faire une petite fiche avec des
coloriages
puis vous expliquer que bientôt la
France va être dans le noir.
Vous l'avez jamais fait ça. Mais
c'est marrant. C'est marrant parce que
le renseignement économique français,
ils font quoi ? Ils font de la pêche.
Parlez-en à votre ami Herboulo parce que
lui il a mis il a mis 10 ans pour pour
avoir pour mettre en place son école de
guerre économique et aujourd'hui vous
savez sans doute que à la direction la
direction de la générale de l'énergie et
du climat à la défense
qui est dirigé par un certain Laurent
Michel que vous avez peut-être entendu à
la commission mais il faut il faut
l'écouter
Bon, dans le bureau voisin, il y a un
organisme ce qui s'appelle l'OFAT qui
est l'office franco-allemand pour la
transition énergétique
avec avec le le mail point ministre.
Bien sûr. Bon, donc
on l'a écouté. Ouais.
Donc moi, le livre que j'ai écrit qui
s'appelle La France dans le noir et qui
à l'époque donc le sous-titre à l'époque
était euh
à l'époque
c'est maintenant. Non, ça moi j'ai la
dernière édition. Oui, la première la
première édition en 2017, c'était la
France dans le noir, les méfets de
l'idéologie en politique énergétique,
France d'Angir
et je cadre le gouin
ce ce livre qui est sorti en 2017
expliquait ce qui était en train de se
passer. Et
les mec de la DGSE, il faisait quoi ?
Toujours de la pêche à la ligne ? J'en
sais rien moi ce qu'il faisait mais en
tout cas ça n'intéressait
les irondelles chinoises
ça n'intéressait personne et moi je
des gseuse c'est pas personne du moins
il s'appelle personne mais
en tout cas en tout cas le dire quand on
est dans un dans un dans une des gens
des gens qui peuvent se déplacer par
rapport on fait quand le coup d'état ?
Ah ben quand tu veux.
Non non non, mais des gens qui arrivent
à se déplacer par rapport à la à la
enfin ce que j'appelle l'aire du temps,
c'est très très rare. Et et même à EDF,
même à EDF.
Dans EDF, on a une affection
particulière.
Ben certes,
pour EDF. Un, parce que c'est les impôts
de nos grands-parents et de comme je
t'ai expliqué dans la cuisine,
ils ont géré le Covid. Je le répète
encore, je suis infiniment désolé. Un
jour, je partagerai des données
anonymisées que nous on nous a envoyé
pendant la crise Covid.
Chers Français, je tiens à vous le dire,
vous pouvez être fier d'DF. Ils ont géré
le Covid mieux que tout ce qui est
autour de nous pendant que tout le monde
courait comme des poulets sans tête.
Mais tu sais, tu sais, moi je je dis
constamment parce que il y a il y a un
autre élément, c'est que ce
démantellement auquel on assiste, on a
coupé le RTE, le Nedis et on est en
train de découper le reste. Et puis
surtout on a créé une une concurrence
artificielle avec des fournisseurs
alternatifs qui sont la ruine. On
revient on reviendra là-dessus parce que
c'est très important mais
non mais ce que je parce que je reviens
sur le EDF n'est plus un service public
puisque il n'a plus les prérogatives de
service public et je suis fasciné
par l'ADN de service public qui reste
dans cette entreprise. la façon dont les
gens aujourd'hui parce que toi tu parles
du Covid mais le travaux qui ont été
faits sur de réparation sur le PR et
surtout de pour pour réparer ce problème
de corrosion sous contrainte qui est
apparu, c'est absolument extraordinaire
la façon dont les gens se se sont
mobilisés, motivés
alors que d'une certaine manière
Ils n'ont ils n'ont plus la enfin ils
n'ont pas la responsabilité
d'approvisionner la France en
électricité. C'est pas plus que total ou
que pauvre ou euh dire aujourd'hui et
quand c'est c'est quand même très
intéressant de voir que alors qu'on les
a mis dans cette situation de ne plus
avoir cette responsabilité, dès qu'il y
a un problème d'alimentation qui
apparaît, le ministre appelle le
président des DF en lui disant "Il faut
que vous preniez vos responsabilités."
Mais quelle responsabilité ? Il l'a
plus. Et donc euh alors peut-être qu'on
peut revenir mais donc je dire moi je je
concours à cette à cette louange sur je
suis fasciné
par ce qui reste ce qui continue
d'exister plutôt qui reste comme comme
sens du service public et comme comme
dévotion à l'intérêt général chez EDF.
C'est c'est fascinant. Donc pour revenir
sur
la question aujourd'hui, on a créé alors
au motif de
la dérégulation et de et de la
concurrence,
un système totalement absurde dans
lequel
pour pour que cette concurrence
apparaisse,
EDF doit vendre à ses concurrents
euh le quart de sa production 100 TW.
Je me fais la l'avocat du diable. C'est
normal Hervé, il faut partager la rente
nucléaire.
Oui.
Alors, il se trouve que
casse pas les dents.
Il se trouve non non
mais je sais bien que c'est l'argument.
En l'occurrence
je
je sais bien que c'est l'argument. La
rente nucléaire, je comprends pas ce
qu'elle veut dire. EDF est une
entreprise qui a financé ses
investissements comme toutes les autres
entreprises de production d'électricité
ont financé leurs investissements. EDF a
financer ces investissements dans le
nucléaire qui fait DDF l'entreprise de
production d'électricité la plus
efficace d'Europe. Bon euh pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faudrait faire partager si
le gaz était à 2 € le le MWAW ? Euh on
ferait pas partager la rente gazière
allemande par EDF. Je veux dire, c'est
quoi le sujet ? Au quel à quel motif on
devrait partager un investissement
d'entreprise qui qui se fait un succès
et qui a permis de baisser le prix de
l'électricité en France d'une façon
continue pendant 50 ans. Et donc 50 ans,
on pay combien à à franc équivalent ?
Je sais pas. Bon, en gros
400 € le MW à franc équivalent il y a 50
ans ? Non.
Euh même pas. 32 32 le coût c'était
avant le parc nucléaire.
Ah, je peux pas dire, je sais pas. Mais
en tout cas en tout cas depuis la
naissance des DF les prix alors que les
prix on n'ont fait que baisser en franc
constant. Alors que quand je suis rentré
en DF dans les années 80,
le tiers du chiffre d'affaires d'DF,
c'était le remboursement de sa dette
et que la dette, elle a été entièrement
contractée par EDF et entièrement
remboursée par EDF. et même euh Giscar à
une époque pour des raisons euh de
balance des paiements a obligé DF à
emprunter sur le marché en dollars
emprunter des dollars euh alors que EDF
ne dépensait 0 dollars et donc il avait
promis que il assurait le le risque de
change, ce qui n'a pas été le cas. Et
donc a remboursé à 10 à à 10 € à 10
francs le dollar de un dollar qu'elle
avait emprunté à 4 mais enfin bon et
donc EDF a subventionné l'État, c'est
pas l'inverse. Donc effectivement
c'est est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
la vache allée des politiques la
variable d'ajustement des politiques ?
Évidemment évidemment. Bah on l'a vu
récemment encore.
Tu me fais candide hein.
Oui oui mais non mais c'est c'est
évident.
Et et là aussi toutes les années 90, moi
je me souviens euh euh
être avoir été en but avec l'esprit de
l'aire du temps, mais vous faux
fonctionnair et il faut privatiser tout
ça et cetera. C'était l'esprit c'était
l'esprit de l'époque la cocaïne de 90.
Ouais. Ouais.
Et donc alors pour revenir
pour revenir
là parce que je voudrais je voudrais
développer un peu cette cette question
des fournisseurs alternatifs et des
conséquences parce que
les fournisseurs alternatifs
jusqu'en 2020
donc acheté de la de ce qu'on appelle
l'arène puisque c'est la loi donc à 42 €
le MWh
la production des DF mais jusqu'en 2020
le prix de l'électricité sur le marché
était inférieur à 42 € le MW
parce que beaucoup de renouvelable parce
que le gaz était pas cher et cetera et
donc
il faisait des s'approvisionnait en
partie à la reine et en partie sur le
marché et donc il faisait des offres en
dehors en dessous des prix des DF et
donc ils ont pris 1 million de euh de
clients DDF par an en gros et au début
il y en a eu trois puis 5 puis 10 puis
100 fournisseurs alternatifs. C c'est
c'est là aussi c'est des milliards.
Et donc
au point que en 2020
les fameux fournisseurs alternatifs y
compris total
parce que le le prix de l'électricité
sur le marché était tombé très bas ont
rompu leurs leur contrat d'arène
en disant ben finalement on a plus
besoin
bien avant le bien avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine euh tension sur
le gaz en septembre 2021.
Et là, les fournisseurs alternatifs
disent "Ah ben attendez, non mais ça va
pas 100 TW d'arène, ça suffit pas. Il
nous en faut 160".
Alors ce que vous savez probablement
pas, c'est que l'arène est liée
au tarifs régulés de vente de
l'électricité
et c'est pour avoir l'autorisation de
vendre
pour protéger pour que les Français
bénéficient de la rente nucléaire.
On a inventé ce système de la Rène au
motif que ça allait créer de la
concurrence. la direction de la
concurrence française et la direction de
la concurrence
de la commission ont dit "Mais vous êtes
sûr que vous allez créer de la
concurrence à la production en faisant
ça ? Ça paraît quand même assez étrange
mais bon puisque vous voulez vous allez
le faire parce c'est une proposition
française.
On a les noms des gens qui ont fait la
proposition. Ben bien sûr, c'est la
commission Champsort
et on a le nom du président secrétaire.
Non, je pas mais on peut trouver, c'est
très facile. Bon, en tout cas
et là-dessus, la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
qui est le bras armé de cette parce que
maintenant il faut bien que quelqu'un
décide
régule puisqu'il y a plein de gens
a décidé que le tarif régulé résulterait
d'un d'un calcul dans lequel il y aurait
70 % d'arène, je crois, ou 75 % et 25 %
du prix. prix du euh
du spot,
sauf
quand alors donc si le spot augmente et
ben le prix le TRV augmente
mécaniquement
et ça je crois c'est sur le spot des 6
derniers mois.
Mais si la demande d'arène
augmente
et que les les les fournisseurs
alternatifs demandent plus de 100W
d'arène,
alors la part
d'arène dans le calcul du TRV diminue
au profit de la part du prix du prix de
l'électricité sur le marché.
Et donc comme ils en ont demandé 160 en
en septembre, c'est la raison pour
laquelle le 4 février
le calcul de la creux conduisait à une
augmentation de 50 % de l'électricité.
Et
108 %, c'est ça ? Non non non, ça c'est
1er février 2023, ça 97 % mais en en 1er
février 2022 c'était 5 50 % et comme
c'est impossible d'augmenter
l'électricité de 50 %
sans se faire couper la tête
sans se faire couper la tête ce qui est
pas arrivé depuis longtemps à aucun roi
coucou Ricou
on a l'État a décidé de prendre une part
et de de donner une autre part DF
l'autre part consistant
a euh donné
20 terw de plus d'arène à 49 €. Ce qui
fait que DF qui avait vendu son
électricité évidemment euh parce que FF
garde pas l'électricité
a été obligé de la vendre à 49 € et de
se réalimenter sur le marché coût 8 à
500 balles le MAW
coût 8 milliards.
Bon et donc quand vous me demandez si
EDF est la vache à du gouvernement, la
réponse est oui. Alors depuis ça s'est
encore amélioré.
Ça s'est encore amélioré parce que
maintenant que le maintenant que le prix
les prix de
spot sont très élevés,
qu'est-ce que font les fournisseurs
alternatifs ? Alors, il y a ceux qui ont
mis la clé sous la porte, Leclair,
maintenant il y en a plus qu'une que
quelques dizaines, il y en a plus 100.
Mais ceux ce ceux qui existent ceux qui
existent encore, ils savent comment
faire. Alors, ils augmentent parce que
ils ont des contrats qui ne sont pas euh
soumis au TRV, au tarifs régulés. Ils
augmentent de 50 100 % 200 % multiplient
par 5 par 10
les le prix de l'électricité pour leurs
clients qui disent
boulangers sont très contents. Les
boulangers sont très contents. Mais il y
a pas mais il y a pas que les
boulangers, il y a des personnes privées
qui euh qui payaient euh 700 € par euh
par an et qui sont tout d'un coup à 4500
€ par an. Et donc euh c'est la panique.
Et donc euh les fournisseurs alternatifs
candides leur disent "Mais attendez,
vous avez une solution qui est prévue
par la loi, vous pouvez retourner chez
EDF." Et donc il retourne chez EDF et
donc
vos pays avant.
Non non
non
mais rien du tout.
On leur laisse la note de 4500 balles et
on va chez EDF. Ah bah non, mais c'est
c'est le contrat le contrat à venir. Ah
oui,
donc pour les décourager de rester chez
les fournisseurs alternatifs,
il les augmente et donc il il retourne
chez EDF et donc EDF est aujourd'hui en
train de récupérer 1 million de de de
clients par an.
Or, cette l'électricité que la que la
loi oblige DF à vendre à ses à ses
clients qui reviennent,
elle l'a pas donc é obligé de l'acheter
sur le marché. Donc on est dans cette
situation totalement absurde dans
laquelle EDF est capable alors peut-être
cette année il y a eu un peu de mais en
gros fourni 90 % peut-être 95 % de la
consommation française à un prix fixe
qui est celui du nucléaire plus
l'hydraulique
et que
et qui est autour de 60 entre 60 et 70 €
le MW
et du faite de cette organisation de la
Ren et cetera, les TRV,
usine à gaz, on peut dire
c'est moins c'est c'est c'est absolument
des mant et donc alors que les coûts de
production n'ont pas bougé, les gens
sont obligés de payer l'électricité deux
à trois fois plus cher qu'avant.
Pourquoi ? À cause du marché de
l'électricité et
et de son organisation et de la reine.
Donc moi, j'ai deux suggestions.
Apprendre le cri du dindon,
non de beaucoup plus efficace.
affer les fourches qui seront pas qui
seront pas retenus parce que euh la
première c'est d'arrêter les subventions
aux on verra même pas il y a pas besoin
d'arrêter les
énergie renouvelable
voilà intermittente hein je
arrêter les les subventions parce que
les les ce qui
ça va en Chine en Allemagne
essentiellement mais en plus ça faut ce
qu'on soi-disant c'est soi-disant c'est
pour faciliter le marché
Mais comment est-ce que on peut
justifier de subventionner
des énergies pour dans un marché
concurrentiel ? Ça n'a aucun sens parce
que j'ai j'ai pas dit mais c'est
implicite.
Les fournisseurs
de d'électricité renouvelable donc
éolienne et solaire
touchent
le même un prix convenu pour toute leur
production, quel que soit le prix spot
et cetera. Et donc quand le quand le
prix tombe à zéro, eux ils vendent ils
le vendent quand même à 92 €.
Ça c'est parce que c'est subventionné.
Et donc alors maintenant ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que ceux qui
avaient des contrats comme ça à 72 ou
quelque chose comme ça, ils disent "Oui
mais maintenant que le marché spot est à
200, on rond les contrats
euh et on va vendre notre électricité
plutôt à 200 qu'à 72." Mais enfin donc
je veux dire il faut
vender bar
il faut supprimer les les
subventions au renouvelable. On verra si
s'il trouve le moyen de continuer à
vivre 100. Ce serait quand même très
intéressant, ça m'étonnerait. Et puis
supprimer la reine et ça c'est
extrêmement simple. Il suffit de
supprimer les tarifs régulés. Si demain
la France dit il y a plus de tarifs
régulés en France,
euh la reine tombe automatiquement et
donc les fournisseurs alternatives avec.
Le problème c'est que je veux dire, ils
ont mis tellement de milliards de côté
que ça va pas être pas un énorme
problème pour eux. En revanche, il y a
quantité de particuliers et
d'institutions françaises qui sont
partis chez ces fournisseurs. En
particulier ministère des armées qui a
jugé intéressant mais plein
d'institutions.
Votre source. Ah ben je ce que je que
c'est très facile à vérifier. Très
facile à vérifier.
Envoie-moi le slide vérification.
Vous avez continué ? On peut envoyer une
petite question une autre ?
Allez-y.
Une autre question. Alors, j'entends
parler partout dans le monde, les
Indiens, les Chinois, les Anglais, les
Américains, même en Afrique.
On va passer à l'uranium, on va passer
au nucléaire.
On en est où ? des contrats de
fourniture de minera d'uranium.
Est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre un peu à de
la tension
sur bah vous comprenez maintenant on va
tous sur l'uranium donc l'uranium bah
les prix vont augmenter
qui est assis sur l'uranium dans le
monde ?
Comment sont négociés les contrats ?
C'est des contrats sur combien de temps
? Entre quel pays ? Et est-ce qui va
bien est-ce qu'il y a des contrats qui
arrivent à terme et qui ne vont pas être
renouvelés ?
Bon alors
cit peut-être pas votre partie.
Non non c'est pas c'est pas ma partie
mais évidemment
vous avez peut-être un copain une copine
qui était travaillé dessus. Oui, oui,
oui,
les deux
un copain et une copine. Euh, bon,
d'abord comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure,
l'uranium
dans la production d'électricité
nucléaire, c'est 1 % du coût. Donc même
si c'était multiplié par 10, ça ferait
pas grand-chose. Donc c'est pas un
sujet. Après, il y a une question de
quantité effectivement
aujourd'hui de l'uranium.
Disponés. Oui, de l'uranium. Il se
trouve qu'il y en a à peu près partout
dans le monde. Il y en a au Canada, il y
en a en Afrique beaucoup. Il y en a en
Australie, il y en a euh
chez les Russes,
j'imagine. Enfin, disons c'est une et
c'est c'est tout à fait clair que on n
pas on est on est on n pas encore estimé
la totalité des réserves existantes
d'uranium. On
n'est pas encore en picque uranium.
Non. D'accord.
Ça c'est c'est très très clair. Vous
avez étudier ce genre de notion de pic
énergétique ?
Oui, bien sûr. Oui.
À partir de quand ?
Bah je l'ai pas étudier proprement. Moi
j'entends parler du pic de
Quand vous avez commencé vos études,
vous en parlez un petit peu ou pas du
tout ?
Je me souviens. Ah ben non, parce que
moi j'ai fait mes études bien avant tout
ça hein. Euh
le
Toi, tu étais pas né toi hein. Vous
pour faire le MIT.
Et donc euh euh non mais le pic uranium
euh il est pas prêt d'arriver et il
faudra un redémarrage vraiment très très
sérieux international dans le monde
entier pour que la la tension commence à
se faire. Cela étant dit et c'est un
point essentiel c'est que on a déjà la
technologie
pour multiplier les réserves d'uranium
par entre 50 et 100. avec les
surgénérateurs parce que Hag, c'est
l'Arabie Saoudite de l'uranium. C'est
ça.
On peut dire ça ? Non, mais le en gros
pour être très simple, l'uranium qu'on
trouve dans les dans les mines, il y a 1
% de même pas 0,9 % d'uranium 235 qui
est celui qui est naturellement ficile
et qu'on utilise en l'enrichissant dans
les centrales nucléaires existantes.
Et puis il y a 98 % du de d'uranium 238
qui lui n'est pas spontanément ficile
et il faut justement des températures
beaucoup plus élevées et des pro des et
de et des projections de neutrons
beaucoup plus actives. On sait faire ce
qu'on l'avait fait à Créalville et ça
existe ailleurs dans d'autres pays en
Russie et en Chine des réacteur à
neutron rapide qui permettront
d'utiliser l'uranium de 138. C'està dire
qu'on multiplie par 100 la les réserves
d'uranium. Donc génère c'est c'est pas
vraiment le sujet.
Les réacteurs au torium sel fondu torium
ça vous parle ? Oui. Bah
oui, ça me parle. Euh au
question Grégoire quit des centrales de
la celle fondue Torium.
Oui, ben elles sont c'est des pistes
dont on parle depuis longtemps et qui
sont aujourd'hui don dont tous les
problèmes techniques ne sont pas résolus
pour les
pour les faire fonctionner à l'échelle
industrielle. Ça fait ça fait 30 ans que
l'Inde essaye
le torium.
parce que il y a pas d'uranium en Inde
et qu'il y a énormément de torium. Mais
et donc aujourd'hui, il y a une
profusion de projet
sur cette base de réacteurs à sel fondu.
Il y en a en Belgique, il y en a en
Italie, il y en a en Suisse,
il y en a beaucoup en Chine, il y en a
aux États-Unis. Et et peut-être qu'un
jour, parce que c'est un énorme
avantage, c'est que c'est ta c'est ta
sécurité passive. C'est-à-dire que quand
on quand on arrête la réaction, il y a
pas de il y a pas de de
ça s'emballe pas.
Ça s'emballe pas. Il y a pas de chaleur
résiduelle qui pourrait conduire à
l'emballement.
Les réacteurs du futur, le PR2, le small
and médium réacteur et les
surgénérateurs Astrid. Vous voulez
rajouter quelques petits mots ?
Le surgénérateur, je viens d'en parler,
c'est évidemment euh ça, comment
dirais-je ? Il faut l'appeler Astrid
quand même.
Mais Astrid c'est un projet euh c'était
un projet de parce que le vrai le le
surgénérateur qui a existé, il
s'appelait Créalville, il a fonctionné
et donc Astrid était la reprise che une
idée de Chirac de de ce projet qui vient
d'être abandonné par bon par un le
commissariat aux énergies renouvelables.
Non, commissariat aux énergies
alternatives, c'est la nouvelle
appellation du CEA.
Je jure.
Et donc
les mecs il restent à l'intérieur, ils
bougent pas.
Non non mais ça s'appelle il y a
vaguement ça s'appelle toujours CEA et
c'est énergie atomique et
quand même
bah en tout cas et énergie alternative.
Bon et donc bon en tout cas il y a
manifestement un petit problème bah si
si vous entendez le le l'administrateur
général parler sur l'avenir, il explique
que c'est très bien d'avoir arrêté
Astrid. Or, dire le le nucléaire, c'est
un tout et précisément
le processus de la de la fermeture du
nucléaire a commencé par la fermeture de
ce qu'on de de Créalville parce que
c'est ça qui permet justement la la
complétude du cycle. On on garde le
plutonium qui résule et le et le et
l'uranium 238 et on le brûle dans des
nouveaux dans des nouveaux réacteurs.
Super Phonix.
Oui, Super Phonix. Phonix d'ailleurs qui
a fonctionné pendant à la perfection
pendant des décennies qui était un petit
réacteur je crois de 300 ou 600 MW et
puis Super Phenniix 1200 MW qui a été
fermé pour des raisons administ pour des
raisons politiques.
Question provoque d'internet ça vous
tente ?
Question provoque
non mais vous voulez que je dise un mot
sur la SMR ou pas ?
Oui pourquoi pas ? Non mais parce que
vous az posé la question
mais bon c'est un plaisir de vous avoir
franchement
je vois pas leur tourner mais c'est pas
bien grave. Ça fait 1h 42 43 secondes
qu'on est en en route. On continue
comme vous voulez.
Continue.
Question. Ouais le les les petites les
petits réacteurs les microréacteurs
nucléaires en Angleterre ils sont très
frayants. Bigat est très frant de ça.
C'est bien c'est pas bien.
Bon
ça fait des des microdangers un peu
partout ou pas ?
Non, c'est les ce sont des réacteurs
assez sûrs.
Contre quoi ? contre le le les risques
d'accidents graves au sens de fusion du
cœur. Et d'ailleurs euh
je fais le parallèle avec euh avec euh
ce qui s'est passé dans le dans le gaz
parce que la technologie des moteurs
d'avion a permis de développer des
turbines à combustion qui sont
extrêmement performantes avec des R
turbines qu'on a vendu il y a pas
longtemps là. Non, pas celle-là
qu'on a vendu où ?
Non, on a on n pas vendu de la rabelle
récemment. Non mais non non vape
arabelle c'est les turbines à vapeur des
centrales nucléaires.
Autant pour moi.
Non mais les turbines à gaz euh et les
cycles combinés à gaz viennent de la
technologie des moteurs d'avion.
C'est ça parce que le les SMR l'idée
vient de des fabricants de moteur de
sous-marin et de et de et de
porte-avion. On s'est dit si on sait le
faire des petits trucs comme ça pour
faire et donc on les gens vivent avec un
moteur de nucléaire
autour d'eux. Enfin il vivent autour de
Donc on s'est dit on va faire on va
faire ça. La question c'est est-ce que
c'est économiquement
industriellement réalisable ? La réponse
n'est pas donnée. Alors, il y a bah
parce que alors je je rappelle un peu
l'histoire, on est parti du 900 MW et
puis on est passé à 1300, puis on est
passé à 1450, puis on est passé à 1600
parce que plus c'est gros, plus les
coûts fixes euh sont amortis.
Et moi, j'avais fait faire une étude
justement au moment de le PR2 pour dire
mais peut-être que 1700 c'est trop.
entre 1000 et 1700, il y a peut-être un
optimum à 13 ou 14. Et la réponse avait
été tant qu'on s'est fabriqué, plus
c'est gros, moins c'est cher.
D'ailleurs, l'expérience de Westingas
avec ses ses réacteurs passifs, c'est
qu'il a essayé pendant de 80 de pas de
des années 80 début des années 80
jusqu'en
jusqu'en 2010 à vendre un AP 600 qu'ils
ont jamais vendu parce que c'est trop
cher à 600 MW et donc ils ont fait un AP
1000 qui reste trop cher et c'est pour
ça que les Chinois l'ont transformé en
AP 14400.
Donc l'idée queon puisse amortir euh un
réacteur de 150 ou 200 MW euh peut-être
mais en tout cas c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui.
Je fais combien de kilomètres avec ma
Cliou avec ça ? pas beaucoup beaucoup
mais mais donc ça veut pas dire qu'
clé électrique.
Oui oui bien sûr. Ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas chercher hein. Ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas continuer. La deuxème le
deuxième élément important sur le sujet
c'est que si un jour
on sait le faire où est-ce qu'on va les
mettre ? Est-ce qu'il y aura les mêmes
exigences de sûreté autour des sites
qu'il y a aujourd'hui de protection
contre les achutes d'avion et cetera ?
Et dans ces cas-là, ça devient
totalement prohibitif. La troisième
chose, c'est que il faut un marché et
que probablement pour que ce soit si ça
a une chance de venir économiquement
économique et industriel, euh il faudra
les faire un peu à la chaîne,
c'està-dire plusieurs par plusieurs par
mois. Et dans ces cas-là,
il y aura pas 36 entreprises dans le
monde qui fabriqueront des réacteurs des
SMR. Et donc voilà. Est-ce que est-ce
que il y aura probablement des
Américains, il y aura peut-être des
Russes et certainement des Chinois parce
qu'ils en construisent déjà ? Euh est-ce
qu'il y a la place pour une entreprise
française ? Euh je l'espère. En tout
cas, ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
espérer, c'est que ce que l'on fait
comme en recherche aujourd'hui en France
pourra servir à être participant dans un
dans un dans une un développement
industriel si si ça s'avère.
Inchallah.
Euh question provoque internet. Exon
savait depuis 1970 les effets délitaires
de son activité sur le climat.
Pourquoi devrait-on faire confiance à
EDF sur la sûreté du nucléaire ? Alors
là, il y a de la défiance par rapport
aux entreprises.
L'internaute nous dit "Bon, Exon, ils
ont pipoté, il le savait, ils ont ils
ont fait du lobbing pour dire que tout
se passe bien, tout va bien se passer.
Est-ce que on peut faire confiance à EDF
?" Alors, vous allez me dire, "On a 25
commissions de sûreté à gauche. 25". Je
veux pas vous dire ça, je veux dire, on
a on a 2300
années
réacteur d'expérience sans sans sans
incident notable
qui n'ont pas été déclarés.
Alors ça m'étonnerait beaucoup. Etf,
c'est un service public, je vous
rappelle, avec un vrai esprit de service
public et pourvu que ça dure.
Question internet
sur le démantellement.
Euh quand on a des sociétés, des États
très endettés,
est-ce que ça va pas être problématique
de démanteler leur réacteur si les
finances publiques sont un peu à sec ?
Est-ce qu'ils vont pas être tentés
de s'accommoder avec
les réglementations préexistantes pour
dire "On va faire durer, on verra ça
plus tard ?" Est-ce que vous comprenez
ma question ?
Non mais bon moi je parle je je peux pas
parler des pays pour lequels il y a pas
de nucléaire encore mais je ne sais pas
si ça correspond à des règles de la IEA
donc l'Agence internationale l'énergie
nucléaire atomique mais en tout cas pour
la France le coût du démantellement il
est provisionné chaque kilowh qui est
vendu à un client aujourd'hui
si c'est du nucléaire
mis en stock pour le démantellement des
centrales.
Vous avez déjà fait rénover votre
appartement ?
Oui.
De vous, on vous annonce des devis
et puis en fait à la fin du devis plus
gère. Oui, mais parce que j'ai qu'un
appartement, j'ai pas la chance d'en
avoir 58.
Bienvenue au club.
En plus, hein.
Non, mais donc ce que je disais tout à
l'heure à propos de
Ça gagne combien un ingénieur comme vous
quand travaillé chez EDF, responsable de
la branche Chine ? Euh franchement, je
m'en souviens pas.
Ah ben non, ça c'est pas une réponse
mais non mais je suis désolé. Euh je
sais pas.
Pareil vous avez le droit de le dire en
France si vous voulez
mais c'était pas en France. Ça devait
être déjà des euros. Euh je sais pas moi
euh
combien je gagné. Euh
c'est votre femme qui fait les comptes.
Bien sûr. Que voulez-vous que ce soit ?
C'est un scandale.
Non mais non mais je sais pas. Je pense
que
peut-être 15000 € quelque chose comme
ça.
Net net ou brut ? Impossible à dire. En
plus, c'était en Chine,
c'était justifié.
XPAT, ça coûte d'une blinde
h
surtout pour se protéger. Vous êtes
marié une française ou une chinoise ?
Française.
Qui vit en Chine ou en France ?
Maintenant en France.
Et vous avez vécu combien de temps en
Chine ?
20 ans.
Vous allez pas me dire que vous avez pas
été approché par les services chinois ?
Jamais.
Mais mais il y a jamais J'ai été
approché par les services français.
Combien de temps ?
Ah non, mais ça a été une fois. Ils
m'ont dit "Est-ce que vous voulez bien
faire du renseignement pour nous ?" J'ai
dit "Non, je peux pas."
Et euh il
vous l'ont proposé gentiment.
Très gentiment.
Ils vous ont fil une carte bleue avec ou
pas ? Non,
non, non, non, rien du tout. C'était
juste
dit vous voulez être patriote
non plus. Ils m'ont dit voilà c'est
un contrôle fiscal. Non,
non, non, non, non, non, non, non. Pas
du tout sur ce tempslà. Mais moi, je
voulais pas
Quel type de renseignement il cherchait.
Mais mais ils m'ont ils m'ont pas dit,
ils m'ont dit "Est-ce que vous voulez
nous donner des renseignements
faire J'ai dit non, je peux pas je peux
ça va me ça va ça ça correspondait pas à
ma vision de ma présence en Chine et
donc je l'ai pas fait. Pour revenir, je
voudrais revenir sur la question de la
IUA parce que au fond,
moi j'ai une une perception depuis
l'origine sur le nucléaire qui est très
décalée et assez provocatrice
pour moi.
Bon, d'abord,
je vois le monde se constituer en
avec tous les risques et tous les mais
en en une en une globalité, ce que moi
j'appelle peut-être de façon un peu
rapide un processus de de conscience
collective
et il y a il y a ce qui participe et a
ce qui participe pas.
Et je
68, ils étaient bons les champignons.
[Rires]
Mais non, mais c'est vrai parce que au
fond la crise qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
pour moi c'est une crise de la prise de
conscience que le monde est fini
et que avant je dire à côté de chez à
côté de son village, il y avait des
espaces et puis il y avait pas de puis
il y avait des ressources et puis
aujourd'hui on a l'impression tout d'un
coup qu'on est trop et que que le monde
est fini et que les ressources sont
finies. C'est pas du tout ma perception
à moi, mais je Et ça crée une forme
d'angoisse collective. Mais le côté
positif de ça, c'est aussi une prise de
conscience de de la solidarité de la
communauté. Alors, il y a les dérives,
on va sauver la terre.
Pour moi, c'est une c'est une dérive
quasi religieuse, mais le côté positif,
c'est bah effectivement, on est tous
ensemble et on a une responsabilité de
solidarité collective.
Et pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce que la dès
que je suis arrivé dans le nucléaire,
j'ai senti ça. C'est la seule industrie
peut-être un peu avec l'aviation mais
pour des raisons différentes. Obligé
d'avoir une sécurité, les avions volent,
les centrales nucléaires ne volent pas
malheureusement.
Mais
ça dépend. Fukushima,
l'hydrogène, ça a bien fait décoller
quand même hein.
Euh le Non, je dis ça parce que si elle
volait, il y aurait une sûreté euh des
une sûreté commune qui serait partagée
par tout le monde. On aurait la même que
les États-Unis, la Chine et cetera.
Alors queaujourd'hui on a des sûretés
qui sont assez différentes et nous on
bénéficie quand même d'une
particulièrement exigeante. Et bon, je
reviens sur sur mon propos pour dire que
c'est la seule industrie qui se soit
organisée dès le premier jour
avec une vision collective sous la
coupe, sous la tutelle de la
inspecte toutes les centrales du monde
qui crée des on a créé des des des
inspections communes de des exploitants
qui vont les uns chez les autres. Le
combustible, pour revenir au
combustible, il n'y a pas 1 mg de
combustible irradié, donc de de déchets
de ce qu'on appelle les déchets
radioactifs qui ne soient pas
répertoriés, identifiés et localisés.
Euh
c'est en France,
pardon,
en France,
dans le monde entier. Bon, en Allemagne
quand même, ils ont balancé un petit peu
taqué dans des mines de créons un peu
dégueulasses. Euh, ils ont balancé un
peu des des fur dans la manche
peut-être. Mais ils savent où ils sont.
Ah ouais ? Non mais ils savent pas ce
qu'ils sont devenus aussi hein.
En tout cas, non mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que
le chien il a fait un trou là. Non non,
moi j'ai enfin je sais pas exactement
mais je crois vraiment que en tout cas
ce que je connais c'est la France et la
Chine. Les États-Unis dans ces pays-là
les l'Allemagne, je pense je suis à peu
près sûr que c'est pareil. C'est vrai
que tout au début du programme nucléaire
on a mis des déchets radioactifs
faiblement radioactif dans l'océan et
puis on s'est tout de suite arrêté.
Faement là vos copains de Greenpeace.
Oui.
Qui se baladait en zodiaque là, qui se
prenait des sur la gueule.
Non non mais ça c'est ça c'est les
essais nucléaires à 1000 €.
Ah oui pardon. Ils font beaucoup de
choses quand même hein.
Bon sont utiles. Non
en tout cas je voulais dire ça parce que
ils sont utiles mis à part pour planter
notre industrie nucléaire.
Bah oui mais
est-ce que vous avez une conscience
écologique ?
Ah bah je pense que oui. Oui.
Vous mangez de la viande ?
Oui.
Beaucoup. Non, mais une conscience
écologique pour moi, la conscience
écologique consiste à faire les choses
avec raison, c'est-à-dire
comment dirais-je,
euh
on gâche beaucoup trop. C'est vrai que
on remplit des poubelles, que
mais que les habitudes de d'excès et de
gâ et de gâchie sont considérables et
que là-dessus, il faut faire des
efforts. De là dire du jour au lendemain
qu'on va plus manger de viande, que on
va plus qu'on qu'on va se balader en
véhicule électrique et que et cetera.
Enfin, je veux dire c'est au motif de
sauver la terre. Moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est l'homme, c'est pas la terre.
Peut-être que l'homme s'identifie trop à
la terre. Non
non non non. Ça vient d'une philosophie
aussi allemande
avec des guerres
en Jonas et cetera de la culpabilité.
L'homme est coupable. D'ailleurs, un
très bon bouquin. Il Oui, il y a un très
bon bouquin de de Ah, je j'ai oublié son
nom. Si Pascal Bruckner
qui s'appelle euh qui s'appelle bon je
retrouverai pas peu importe dans lequel
c'est pas le dernier dernier livre de
Bruno Lemè non
dans lequel il dit
toute la tradition euh judéo-chrétienne
c'est la culpabilité de l'origine et
maintenant on l'a transformé dans la
culpabilité dans le futur. On est
coupable du futur avant
c'est qu'on a fait quand même beaucoup
de merde. C'est-à-dire
bah un exemple
guerre 141 l'Hériite balancé dans la
Manche.
Hm.
Balancé dans les lacs en Suisse un peu
partout euh les déchets de l'armement.
Non mais oui. Non mais d'accord mais je
vous dire
les les les comment ça s'appelle ? Les
polluants éternels qui restent dans le
biotope qui sont recyclés 25. C'est
justement ce dont je voulais parler à
propos du nucléaire parce que justement
le nucléaire ne fait pas ça.
Merci
de votre aide.
Pourquoi il fait pas ça ?
Mais parce que précisément chaque
milligramme est identifié, localisé, on
sait où il est. Ceux qui sont ceux qui
sont faiblement radioactifs ou
moyennement radioactifs sont répertoriés
et mis jusqu'à la fin de leur vie. Et
ceux qui sont très radioactifs. Non non,
ils sont mis comment ? Ils sont sous
hangar. Non, maisant le demie, c'est ça.
Non, mais pas leur demi-vie le jusqu'à
ce que le radi provoque soit du niveau
des radiations naturelles,
donc de ce que la
réglementation euh considère comme étant
acceptable par l'homme. Mais alors, si
vous voulez détail là-dessus,
il faut voir les précautions qui sont
prises dans le domaine du nucléaire.
J'ai vu ça aux États-Unis, ils avaient
ils avaient un site d'enfouissement et
ils se disaient "Bon alors
si on met une pancarte devant marqué
rentrez pas parce que vous allez vous
faire cramer."
Ils sont dit les Américains parce qu'ils
sont pas bêtes, hein. Ils sont dit "Bon,
ils vont peut-être pas comprendre notre
langue, on va mettre un tableau, on va
mettre une image et ils ont mis le criz
le cri,
ils sont dit bon ça ça quand c'était à
Paluel
le
à côté de Palavas les flots
non à côté de de Saint-Valérie
euh
ce qu'on appelle les effluants
radioactifs,
le truc qui dure très longtemps,
non ? des effluents radioactifs,
c'estàdire que
ça coule dessus.
Non, c'est c'est ce qui est produit
dans le dans le fonctionnement habituel
qu'on dilue quelques litres dans des
mètres cubes d'eau de mer. Et donc la
règle,
c'est pas plus que l'homéopathie.
Attendez, attendez, mais laissez-moi
parler. La règle c'est que
si c'est le même poisson qui est sur le
puit de rejet et que il absorbe tout ça
et que c'est ce poisson-là qui est sur
le marché
euh au bout d'un an, la personne qui va
l'acheter n'aura pas plus de doses que
ce qui est normal dans le les effluents
radioactifs, ce qu'on appelle les
effluents radioactif dans les centrales
nucléaires, c'est moins radioactif que
l'eau desviant et le whisky.
Bon, donc
et les crayons de combustible,
il faut voir. Oui, mais on les met pas,
on les jette pas. Ils sont justement
traités, stockés et précisément en
France, on sépare
le plutonium, l'uranium 238
et les déchets dit à haute activité à
vie longue qu'on l' vitrifie et qu'on
descend dans des couches qui ont des une
stabilité
millionnaire
avec en plus la perspective de pouvoir
les remonter le jour où on saura faire
ce qu'on appelle la transmutation,
c'est-à-dire casser ses atomes.
Donc enfin franchement oui, on peut il y
a pas d'industrie qui qui soit aussi
près questionné. Je vais vous organiser
un un petit débat
avec vos copains.
Ou
je peux vous poser une petite question
internet ?
Allez-y.
On la prend au pif.
La France est-elle malade de ses grands
corps et de leur prédation sur l'État ?
OK, je vous laisse réfléchir.
Si ouais.
Pourquoi ne pas avoir développé plus de
réacteurs niveau 4 stock en France pour
2000 ans ? Bon, ça on a déjà parlé.
C'est quoi niveau 4 ?
4e génération. Ouais, je vous laisse
répondre sur
Oui, en fait
la période du grand programme nucléaire
et de la reconstruction de la France et
de l'industrialisation de la France, il
y avait autant de grands corps et ça a
marché très bien. Et pourquoi ? parce
queil y avait
une confiance, le politique faisait
confiance
à ce qu'on peut appeler justement les
grands les grands serviteurs de l'État
qui eux-mêmes faisaient confiance aux
politiques et donc il y avait je veux
dire non non mais Marcel
à l'époque c'était bien
non mais ce que le problème c'est pas
le problème c'est pourquoi je dis ça
c'est parce que
c'est pas que les gens étaient
formidablement mieux qu'aujourd'hui,
c'est que chacun avait ses
responsabilités.
Le gouvernement fixait la vision, la
direction et pas et n'était pas
l'administrateur et le et le
gestionnaire. Et aujourd'hui, le
politique se mêle de tout et moins ils
connaissent et plus ils s'en mêlent.
aujourd'hui. Mais c'est vrai, je veux
dire que que la la façon dont les
ministres et et leur euh et leur
conseiller
court court
cour
leur cours Oui.
Oui. En tout cas, leur conseiller euh
interfère, donne des instructions.
Je veux dire, on a on a on a on a
tellement politisé
le l'environnement industriel que
aujourd'hui c'est plus les industriels
qui le dirigent. Et ça que ce soit que
ce soit
pour moi c'est vraiment ben d'ailleurs
je disais à propos de à propos de le PR
que c'est un réacteur politique. La
P1000 est aussi un réacteur politique
puisqu'il a été choisi pour des raisons
politiques. à partir du moment, je me
souviens d'ailleurs à EDF, à l'époque où
on avait des problèmes de relation avec
ce qui était à l'époque fromatome,
la la règle absolue, c'était on va pas
demander l'arbitrage de l'État parce que
ce sera forcément la plus mauvaise
solution. Il faut se débrouiller entre
nous et pas attendre les solutions
politiques. Et ça, malheureusement euh
c'est une dérive dont je ne sais pas si
elle est récupérable.
Il ne faut pas compter sur ceux qui ont
créé les problèmes pour les résoudre.
C'est ça.
Non, mais en l'occurrence, c'était pas
forcément eux qui avaient créé les
problèmes, mais il faut pas compter sur
ceux qui ne con qui n'ont pas la les
mains dans le cambouille pour dire comme
ça ou les pieds sur terre de résoudre
des problèmes des concrets des gens qui
il faut qu'on les résolve. C'est ceux
qui connaissent les problèmes qui
doivent les résoudre entre eux. C'est
l'arbitrage de de ceux qui sont
avec un peu de transparence quand même.
Pardon ? avec un peu de transparence sur
les problèmes.
Bah oui, bien sûr.
Question : oublie pas qu'il est enlève
tes doigts.
Question internet. Peut-il nous raconter
son vécu à l'époque des accidents de
Ternobyl et Fukushima d'un point de vue
personnel et en tant que gérant de DF ?
Hm.
Alors euh Ternoby, j'étais en Chine donc
je n'ai pas enfin
j'ai mis pas mal de temps à comprendre
bien ce qui s'était passé. Effectivement
c'est c'est un choc alors pas sur la
confiance qu'on a dans le nucléaire
parce que les conditions dans lesquelles
cet accident sont produit sont inouies.
dire
pas si inoui que ça
inoui ?
Bah ils sont pris un un tsunami dans la
tête.
Non non, on parle de Chernoby.
Ah pardon, j'étais sur Fukujouima.
Pardon.
Les conditions dans laquelles cet
accident
un film. Un film
un film. Ils ont ils ont coupé a une une
équipe de de
encore un coup des Allemands.
Non
non
des Russes.
Bah oui forcément.
Non non mais qui sont venus faire des
des essais.
Euh et ils ont coupé toutes les
sécurités, tous les automatismes de
sécurité pour faire les essais en
question.
Bah ça c'est du russe
en tout cas. Euh, il semblerait en plus
qu'ils étaient assez pressés de rentrer
parce que c'était un samedi et que bon
et donc voilà, c'est c'est un truc inoui
en plus c'est un modèle exceptionnel
puisque ces RBMK sont des modèles dans
lequels le le le
fluide de refroidissement c'est du
charbon.
C'est pas un fluide mais c'est le ce qui
est ce qui entoure les éléments
combustibles, c'est du charbon, du
carbone et donc graphite
du graphite. Donc ça a pris feu et tout
a explosé. Bon,
ça fait des petits morceaux partout.
Alors que la même fusion du cœur à
Stream Island, il y a pas eu il y a pas
eu un gram de radioactivité dans
l'atmosphère. Bon,
autour c'est un peu pissé, non ? Non.
Stre Island, zéro zéro.
Donc Ternobyl c'est effectivement une
catastrophe.
Maintenant, il faut voir
euh je veux dire, il faut pas non plus
si vous voulez alors parce que les 10000
morts de Ternoby
ça vient d'une extrapolation
intéressante qui est liée à la théorie
des faibles doses. Alors la théorie des
faibles doses, c'est que si vous prenez
un milici verte par an pendant 100 ans,
c'est comme si vous preniez 100 mic
vertes le même jour. Il fa falloir me
convertir ça en curry parce que bon j'ai
pas
Oui. Ben non mais c'était c'est juste
pour pour la théorie des faibles doses
c'est que l'accumulation
dans le temps est équivalente à la la
totalité de la dose instantanée. C'est
comme si vous disiez
je vais me faire 250 radios du pied
aujourd'hui.
Exactement. C'est comme si vous disiez
moi je bois d'ailleurs il y a des
médecins qui disent ça. Moi je fume une
cigarette par jour.
Et bien au bout d'un an, c'est comme si
j'avais fumé 365 cigarettes le même
jour. C'est pas tout à fait pareil. Or
la théorie des faibles d'ES c'est ça,
c'est que
ça tient pas la route.
Ben je dire c'est quand même sur ça qui
est fondé l'idée queil y a eu 10000
morts de de
à Ternoby alors qu'en fait des il y a
même des pompiers de Ternobyl donc des
mecs qui sont allés sur le sur le site
qui étaient volontaires pour aller à
Fokojima. Donc ils sont pas tous morts.
C'était ceux qui avaient une troisème
couille et un tr Non, c'était lequel ?
Oui, mais ça ça aussi ça fait partie. Il
faut lire il faut lire les profs
provoquiana et cetera. Enfon moi je suis
pas un spécialiste mais il y a des
médecins de radio
justement de sur radiologie qui ont
écrit des sommes sur le sujet. La
théorie des faibles doses ne tient pas
la route. Elle c'est c'est prouvée. Et
les déformations post Tchernobyl, on en
a jamais vu plus après Ternobyl
qu'avant.
Ouais. Non mais
non mais
en Russie du temps de l'Union
soviétique, les colonies de vacances des
gamins qui étaient coincés autour du
réacteur, ça existe toujours.
Je sais pas
quand ils vont prendre les gamins les
mettre un petit peu au soleil.
pense qu'il y a beaucoup
il y a beaucoup il y a beaucoup de de
fantasmes et et justement de
donc c'est pour ça qu'on va vous
organiser un débat volontiers
et et Fukushima
Fushima
Fukushima euh
le seul
les Japonais que qui engagé des par les
mafia
pour les nettoy pardon aussi Fukushima,
il y a eu 20000 morts du fait du tsunami
il y a eu un mort euh du fait de
l'accident de Tiernobyl, c'est un arrêt
du cœur dans un quand on l'a déplacé
et les gens disent et effectivement le
le le conséquences radiologiques de
Fukushima, ça a été le l'exclusion d'une
d'un d'un territoire relativement
important dans lequel on a évacué les
gens. Personne n'est mort de la de
l'accident
de des centrales nucléaires de
Fukushima.
Ouais. Mais l'économie locale, elle en
est où ? Non mais ben justement il ils
sont en train de ils ont dit on aurait
pas dû faire un un espace aussi un
territoire d'exclusion aussi grand et il
commence à à revenir sur cet espace-là
que les gens reviennent chez eux. Non
mais heureusement ce qui est vrai c'est
que la plupart euh les vents étaient
dans le bon sens et la pluie dans le bon
sens puis il y a personne qui habitait à
côté de chez eux
et c'est allé vers la mer. Bon non mais
cela dit si vous voulez bien sûr c'est
un accident mais encore une fois quand
on lit et on continue de lire et on
continue de voir des des des gens de
gagnant des responsabilités j'ai pas de
nom tout de suite mais enfin je pourrais
les retrouver qui disent
à Fukou le le l'accident de Fukushima a
fait 20000 morts euh il y en a même qui
disent qu'il a provoqué le tsunami. Donc
non mais non mais OK mais c'est
les Russes n'étaient pas là avec leur
super torpill de tsunami.
Bon donc je il y a une forme
d'exploitation de la de surexploitation
de ces trois accidents. En tout cas, si
vous si vous avez la chance de lire mon
livre, vous verrez que en gros le
nucléaire avec tout ce qui est arrivé
euh fait à peu près, je sais pas moi,
des des milliers des milliers de morts
de moins que le charbon.
C'est je peux je peux vous Oui, mais ça
c'est sûr. Je peux vous ouvrir une
parenthèse. C'est une surexploitation du
risque ou c'est simplement parce que
chez EDF, bon, on est on sait faire des
réacteurs mais on est des banques en
communication.
Mais alors des branques, vous
savez,
je reviens sur un peu sur le sujet tout
à l'heure. On est moi quand je suis
arrivé DF, les mecs c'étaient pas des
branques en communication mais on entend
que ce qu'on veut entendre. Encore une
fois, quand j'ai écrit ce livre là qui
est aujourd'hui a une certaine
résonance.
Il y a 6 ans quand il est sorti,
comment il s'appelle le livre déjà ?
La France dans le noir.
12 € combien ? Comment
combien il coûte
ce la nouvelle version ? Euh je vous dis
tout de suite 12,90 €. Ah oui, c'est
beaucoup plus cher que l'enne.
Mais la première édition, elle est moins
chère.
Et on peut colorier dedans ou
Ah ben, on peut écrire tout ce qu'on
veut.
Euh
personne ne voulait enfin c'était
vous pouvez toujours si si les gens
veulent pas entendre, vous pouvez
toujours dire ce que vous voulez hein.
Et donc
là, c'est pareil quand quand vous êtes
dans un monde, c'est comme à propos de
la dérégulation dans les années 90, la
financiérisation, dire le contraire
c'était bah OK, vous êtes des DF, vous
êtes nul, les fonctionnaires machin et
cetera le service public mais ça existe
plus. Vous savez que bon le aujourd'hui
parler de service public c'est
complètement déplacé.
Pas du tout.
Bah non, mais ça dépend où. Ça dépend
où. Mais euh
service public, c'est nécessaire surtout
production électrique.
Ah oui. Bah oui.
Euh on a parlé du torium,
on a parlé tout un tas de choses. Est-ce
que vous voulez aborder d'un sujet ? La
sobriété, ça vous parle ?
Alors la sobriété, ça s'appelle en fait
récession subie ou récession subie. Non,
si vous voulez que que on dise que
récession heureuse,
non, je veux dire que c'est pas la peine
que
croissance négative.
Non, moi je fais je fais pas partie de
ces gens-là.
La la
je pense que on n'est pas obligé d'être
tous obèses
et donc une certaine forme de sobriété
n'est pas de mauvaise. Si elle est d à
l'incapacité à gérer le collectif comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui à propos de
l'électricité, c'est un scandale. Obligé
à la sobriété parce qu'on sait pas
gérer, parce queon a ruiné notre
système, ça c'est pas normal. Et donc
dire c'est c'est deux choses
complètement différentes pour moi. Il y
a de sobriété positive qui est bah oui,
on gâche pas, on on est on fait pas on
n'est pas dans on n'est pas tous les
jours dans l'excès. Un petit excès de
temps en temps, pourquoi pas ? Mais bon
euh mais voilà, on est on est un peu
responsable de soi et de son
environnement. Mais euh dire maintenant
l'abondance est finie,
il va falloir se serrer la ceinture
parce qu'on a pas été foutu de de
poursuivre une politique
légitime et efficace. Alors c'est un
scandale.
Quand vous dites "On n'a pas été foutu,
vous nous mettez dedans ou vous mettez
que la classe dirigeante
Je
bon je vais pas me mettre dedans parce
que j'ai constamment réagi à ça la
preuve. Et donc mais je j'étais
j'avais une responsabilité
opérationnelle mais je reviens toujours
la même chose c'est que vous pouvez
toujours raconter ce que vous voulez.
Moi quand on a fermé Créalville était
outré mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire
contre le premier ministre ? Et dans un
comment il s'appelait à l'époque
je sais pas.
et et dans une et dans un environnement
où 80 % des gens pensent ça pensent que
donc vous pouvez toujours essayer de
vous exprimer, on ne vous écoute pas. Et
moi je me souviens de avoir dans les
années
2010 dit en réunion
dex
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire 50 %
d'énergie nucléaire ? Comment on va
faire les 50 % autres ? Et le
renouvelable, c'est un fantasme. Mais
bon, une fois que j'ai dit ça,
c'est pas ça suffit pas pour faire la
politique.
Deux questions euh que je j'attrape au
vol. Quelles seraient les conséquences
pour la France et sa souveraineté
industrielle et militaire avec un
découpage DDF façon Hercule 2.0 ? 2è
question. Pourquoi les centrales
nucléaires américaines sont refroidies
avec le recyclage des eaux usées et pas
les centrales françaises ?
Avec le recyclage des eaux usées ?
Alors, je sais pas d'où il tient ça. Il
y a pas la il a pas la source. Pas trop
ce que ve dire. Mais alors la première
question
euh voilà,
l'électricité comme je disais tout à
l'heure ne se stock pas. Il faut donc
prévoir à l'avance
euh la consommation
et ensuite s'ajuster la production à la
consommation d'une façon constante,
encore une fois instantanément. à court,
à moyen et à long terme. Et donc il faut
être capable de il faut être capable de
faire ses prévisions et ensuite de gérer
un parc avec des moyens de production
différents.
Et c'est ça qui a qui a fait le la force
du système. Si on aujourd'hui, je vais
donner un exemple à propos du découpage
entre EDF production et le réseau.
aujourd'hui le le réseau donc RTE qui
est
soi-disant enfin théoriquement
responsable de l'ajustement instantané
entre la consommation et la production,
il est pas responsable de la production
et la preuve c'est quand il y a pas
assez de production ben il dit on va
faire des coupures. Il y a personne qui
soit en France aujourd'hui responsable
de la production. Non mais on va faire
du délestage.
Oui. Bah oui mais enfin c'est ça
commence par du délestage et ça fait ça
fait tout de suite trop agressif. Ouais,
d'accord. Mais bon
et donc non mais je je reviens à ça
parce que aujourd'hui j'ai entendu
RTE dire ah mais attendez nous plus il y
a de renouvelable plus on est content
parce que c'est vrai que s'il y a une
chance sur un million que s'il y a une
chance sur un million que le jour où on
a besoin à la pointe il y a un peu de
vent, bah c'est toujours ça de prix.
Les milliards que ça coûte, c'est pas le
c'est pas son problème,
c'est le problème du producteur. C'est
lui qui paye.
À l'époque où RTE a été intégré, il y
avait un seul une seule entité qui
optimisait le service public pour dans
l'intérêt général commun. Aujourd'hui,
supposons que on découpe l'hydraulique,
on fait une entreprise, le nucléaire, on
fait une entreprise, le gaz, on fait une
entreprise, le renouvelable, on fait une
entreprise, mais je veux dire, qui est
responsable de l'ajustement et il y a
plus de service public, c'est fini.
Il a plus de responsable.
Bah déjà, il y en a plus. Comme j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure, c'est c'est une
réminiscence de responsabilité qui
retombe sur EDF, mais elle en est pas
véritablement en droit responsable. Mais
si on mais mais chaque fois qu'on on
qu'on augmente le le découpage, on
détruit la responsabilité et le service
public.
Hervé, ça fait 2h19 et 31 secondes que
nous sommes ensemble. Alors, je veux
bien pousser le délire mais on est un
peu fatigué aujourd'hui, donc on va être
obligé de vous faire revenir un de ces
quatre.
Je vais vous poser
pas une question. Je vais vous demander
de me conseiller de nous conseiller
trois bouquins qui ont été importants
dans votre vie ou des bouquins que vous
avez vu qui vous ont un petit peu
trois
titillé les quatre
qui vous ont un peu titillé les
neurones.
Ouais.
Dom confondu.
Tout domaine confondu. Alors
celui qui remonte le plus ancien pour
moi qui m'a marqué c'est l'être un jeune
poète.
Reiner Maria Code.
Le deuxième c'est
regard sur le monde actuel de Paul
Valérie.
Fascinant de de prévision de ce qui est
en train de se passer écrit dans les
dans les années entre 20 et et 30.
Incroyable.
Le troisème c'est parce que c'est une
c'est une pour moi une une lecture plus
récente mais qui est fondamentale
dans le dans les enjeux qui qui de mon
point de vue sont en train de se jouer
aujourd'hui la société, c'est
l'enracinement de Simon Veale.
Et le dernier qui est tout à fait d'un
are style,
c'est
Az China One de Kishorim Abouani qui est
un un diplomate professeur de Singapour
mais d'origine indienne et qui explique
ce que l'Occident est en train de ne pas
comprendre sur ce qui se passe dans le
monde en restant les États-Unis en
particulier complètement crispés sur
leur position dominante et qui va
exploser si se crispe trop alors que ce
serait l'intérêt communif
de de voir que le monde est divers
et et
peut se construire ensemble dans sa
diversité.
Je voudrais un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose qui va rester impérissable
sur internet.
Ayez confiance
en qui ?
En vous,
dans les autres et dans la vie.
Hervé Mchenna. Merci.
[Musique]